[Musique]
Jean Messias, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Jean Messi tout le monde me connaît.
Donc
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait avant
d'être Jean Messière ? Bah écoutez, moi
j'ai une vie, une trajectoire assez
complexe.
Euh je suis comme ça peut se voir issu
de l'immigration.
Pourquoi ça peut se voir ?
Bah l'assimilation ayant des limites, je
serai jamais un grand blond germanique
si vous voulez. Donc
donc
avec des rageous aussi peut-être.
Voilà. Donc je suis arrivé en France à
l'âge de 8 ans. Je ne savais pas parler
un mot de français.
Ta mamê.
Euh voilà, je suis d'origine égyptienne.
Coolou tamême.
Coolou. Meille meilleur meille meilleur
c'est à fou
à
grâce à mes parents d'abord et à ma
maîtresse d'école qui m'a appris qui m'a
fait des cours particuliers en même
temps qu'elle faisait cours au reste de
la classe euh et bien j'ai pu apprendre
la langue française.
Et pour la petite histoire, quand j'ai
réussi le concours de LENA, 25 ans plus
tard, j'ai téléphoné à cette maîtresse
d'école qui m'avait accueilli en 1978
par un beau matin d'octobre à Mulouse en
Alsace pour lui l'informer que le petit
Égyptien qu'elle avait accueilli 25 ans
plus tôt était devenuarque. Et donc ce
fut un grand moment d'émion. D'ailleurs,
j'invite vos téléspectateurs à voir la
petite vidéo témoignage de ma maîtresse
d'école sur Twitter
qui est en tweet épinglé. Donc elle sera
pas très difficile à à identifier. Euh
voilà. Donc ensuite bah j'ai fait des
études d'économie. Je suis économiste de
formation. J'ai un doctorat en sciences
économiques. J'ai travaillé notamment
sur les zones monétaires optimales et
sur la coordination des politiques
budgétaires face au traités de Mastrich
à Amsterdam. J'ai soutenu ma thèse de
doctorat en 1999, juste avant l'entrée
en vigueur de l'euro. Malheureusement,
c'était une thèse un peu souverainiste,
hein, puisque j'ai essayé de démontrer
que euh un projet de d'Union européenne
sans union politique préalable était un
projet extrêmement coûteux euh ou alors
un projet qui était voué à l'échec. Soit
il était très coûteux, soit il était
voué à l'échec. On a vu en 2010-212 à
l'occasion de la crise financière que
c'était un projet très coûteux euh qui a
donc coûté des des centaines de
milliards d'euros.
Euh et donc comme j'ai je me suis fait
barrer la porte à l'université pour
cette raison euh puisque toute le à
l'époque euh tout le toute la recherche
économique française était eurobéate
hein. Euh ils ont décidé le Conseil
national des universités dans son
rapport a dit que j'étais un footeur de
guerre. Ce sont les mots euh tout
simplement parce que j'avais eu le
malheur euh de soutenir une thèse de
doctorat qui vouait la la zone euro à
l'échec euh ou à la ruine. Bon euh et
donc bah j'ai été obligé de voilà de
rebondir. Donc j'ai passé les concours
administratifs. Je précise que j'avais
été diplomé de science pour Paris
pendant mes études universitaires parce
que j'ai fait un double cursus et que
j'avais été admissible au concours de
l'ENA une première fois en externe. Et
donc à la suite euh de mon échec à
devenir ce que je voulais être en fait
un maître de conférence puis un
professeur des universités, j'ai retenté
les concours administratifs et j'ai eu
le le concours de l'ENAT fin 2002. Donc
je fais partie de la promotion 2003-2005
Romain Gary euh de l'ENA. Euh
et donc j'ai choisi de servir au
ministère des armées en 2005.
J'ai servi en tant que conseiller
économique et financier du chef
d'étatmajor de l'armée terre de 2005 à
2007.
Ensuite, je suis parti faire ma mobilité
à la direction générale du trésor dans
le réseau international. J'étais
successivement conseiller financier pour
le Moyen-Orient
donc basé auprès de l'ambassadeur de
France aux Émirats arabes unis mais avec
une compétence régionale. Donc je gouver
tous les pays du golf, l'Iran, l'Irak et
le Yémen. Et ensuite, j'ai fait
exactement la même chose. Donc
conseiller financier pour le proche
Orient basé auprès de l'ambassadeur de
France au Liban, donc pour couvrir tous
les pays du Levent.
Euh je suis ensuite rentré dans
l'administration centrale d'État en 2013
pour être euh rapporteur pour le livre
blanc de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale de 2013.
C'était quoi le titre ? C'est les les
Non, ça c'était 2009008, c'est les
répercussions du réchauffement
climatique sur le livrebement de la
défense française. Ça
alors là c'était les répercussions de la
crise financière.
D'accord.
Puisque c'était 2013 et donc où nous
étions en train de sortir de la crise
financière. Donc effectivement le livre
blanc portait sur les nouveaux risques
en identifiant ce risque économique et
financier qui pour l'instant
en tout cas la fragilité la
vulnérabilité de la France aux
problématiques financières qui n'avait
pas ou peu été identifié jusqu'à présent
le livre blanc de la défense et de la
sécurité nationale de 2013 lui faisait
la parbelle euh voilà donc ensuite je
suis parti au Qatar pour la la société
Nextter pour essayer donc dans le cadre
d'un contrat que nous essayons de faire
signer euh au Qatari pour la vente de
380 VBCI.
Tu dis ce que
véhicule blindé de combat d'infanterie.
Donc c'est des véhicules 8 enfin 44 ou
enfin des 88 en fait voilà des véhicules
de c'est de des véhicules blindés hein.
Euh c'est un contrat qui était assez
ancien. Puis bon, comme je suis
parfaitement arabophone et que je
connaissais bien les pays du golf,
malheureusement, j'ai eu un voilà un
événement familial qui a fait que je
suis rentré plutôt que prévu au sein de
du ministère de désarmée à nouveau et je
me suis engagé en politique au
Rassemblement national fin 2014. Euh
voilà, donc j'ai envoyé une à l'époque
une lettre à Marine Le Pen qui a
répondu, elle m'a reçu et donc j'étais
un de ses conseillers
euh les plus écoutés d'abord en
sous-marin parce que je je ne je ne
souhaitais pas initialement
afficher mon identité. Et puis ensuite,
j'ai basculé en 2016 euh dans une
interview qu'a accordé Marine Le Pen
après une longue période de jeûne
cathodique. Marine Le Pen a accordé une
inter une longue interview au magazine
Valeur Actuelle le 4 juillet 2016 dans
laquelle elle annonçait publiquement mon
arrivée dans son équipe de conseillers
rapproché et à partir de là a commencé à
la fois mon engagement politique de
manière officielle et également ma
médiatisation.
Donc elle m'a nommé ensuite euh
coordinateur de son projet présidentiel
pour sa campagne de 2017.
Euh donc voilà, j'ai connu là à ce
moment-là mes premiers plateaux de télé,
de radio et cetera. Euh et puis j'étais
également candidat au législative dans
l'en circonscription de l'INE.
Et à la fin de cette séquence électorale
de 2017, ma carrière politique et ma
carrière médiatique aurait pu s'arrêter
là. D'ailleurs, beaucoup de personnes
qui étaient engagées auprès de Marine Le
Pen à ce moment-là. Une fois terminé euh
l'année 2017, ils ont complètement
disparu des radars.
Quelle n'a pas été ma surprise euh à la
rentrée
2017 en septembre de voir que les
chaînes de télévision continuent à
m'inviter. C'était à la fois C News,
BFM, LCI, France Info TV. Et d'ailleurs,
je me souviens d'une interview politique
que j'avais accordée à Sonia Mabrou le
matin dans la matinale de C News euh une
minute avant le la prise de direct,
Sonia Mabrou me dit "Mais il faut vous
présenter comment ?" Oui, parce que
j'avais plus de titre. À ce moment-là,
l'élection présidentielle était
terminée, l'élection législative était
terminée. Je n'avais pas encore de titre
officiel auprès du Rassemblement
national et donc j'ai dit à Sonia Marcou
: "Ben écoutez, présentez-moi comme un
conseiller de Marine Le Pen, ce qui
était factuellement vrai mais qui
n'était pas officialisé en quelque
sorte.
Euh donc il y avait une demande de Jean
Messia indépendante
de l'actualité politique et médiatique
qui était celle de l'élection
présidentielle.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais maintenant ?
Bah aujourd'hui, je suis donc engagé
auprès d'Euroconquêt. Je suis candidat à
l'élection municipale dans la ville
d'Evreux en Normandie. Euh et donc
voilà, je je travaille pour le parti au
concret. Je suis son porte-parole
d'ailleurs et je suis en train d'écrire
un livre en parallèle.
Ça plus tard.
Qu'est-ce que ça te fait quand on te dit
que tu es l'arabe de service ?
Euh,
j'aurais aimé qu'on me traite
comme le m'aurait traité dans un pays
normal de français modèle.
Parce que à la vérité, qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
Lorsqu'un pays est fier de ce qu'il est,
il est aussi fier d'accueillir
des gens qui lui ressemblent et qui ont
toute une trajectoire d'assimilation à
ce qu'il est ce pays. Et donc un pays
qui est fier de ce qu'il est, il
mettrait en permanence sur les plateaux
de télévision des gens qui sont venus
d'ailleurs et qui sont devenus d'ici,
ce qui est mon cas.
Or la le problème c'est que comme nous
avons un système antinational qui dirige
la France, un système haïsant la France,
dites-moi quelles immigrations vous
mettez en valeur, je vous dirai quel
français vous êtes. C'est sûr que quand
on met en valeur des immigrations comme
les Yassine Bellatar, les Daniel Obono,
les Rokaya Dialo,
des immigrations qui haïsent la France
au fond.
Ils haïsent pas la France,
ils haïsent la France. Bah Roala Dialou,
elle a ses opinions mais je pense pas
qu'elle existe la France.
Bah excusez-moi mais quand vous écoutez
Rokaya Dialo, qu'est-ce qu'elle dit de
la France ? À part que la France est un
pays raciste, est un pays esclavagiste,
est un pays qui fait de la ségrégation
de manière systémique, excusez-moi, on a
connu preuve d'amour un peu plus
évidente.
Tu veux que je te vois ou que je te je
te tue toi ?
Comme tu veux.
Je te donne un exemple. Moi, j'ai mon
meilleur pote qui est marocain et
français, il est marocain d'origine. Il
a vécu tellement de racisme
qu'il a ouvert tous ses business en
Afrique. Il a fait fortune en Afrique et
maintenant il vit à Dubaï depuis 14 ans.
Alors la France, je me fais l'avocat du
diable.
Il il a vécu du racisme genre c'était
Mais je comprends.
Sauf que il est surdoué.
Il a au début il a fait STAPS.
Ouais. Il s'est rendu compte il s'est
rendu compte que à chaque fois il se
prenait des remarques de travers. Il est
issu d'une zone à éducation prioritaire,
famille de se ou hfants.
Je connais euh
il en a pris plein la gueule.
Ses frangin ont pris plein la gueule.
Ses sœurs on a pris plein la gueule. Un
peu moins parce qu'elles sont
magnifiques.
Et et donc il a décidé maintenant on
arrête les conneries. Il a commencé à
ouvert un business en Belgique. Il dit
ça a bien marché. Ensuite, il a ouvert
des business en Afrique du Nord, en
Afrique centrale et puis il a fait
fortune comme ça et maintenant au lieu
de payer des impôts en France, il paye
des impôts à Dubaï à 13 %.
Mais ça je
donc Crocala Dialo, elle a peut-être
raison un peu. Non
non mais la le problème si vous voulez
c'est le le problème est si tu veux
aussi
si tu veux si tu veux le problème c'est
le problème de la poulet de l'œuf.
Est-ce que c'est en promouvant des
immigrations haineuses de la France
qui au fond n'ont qu'un seul qu'une
seule conséquence ? c'est de dégoûter
les français de l'immigration parce
qu'excusez-moi, moi si j'étais un
français de souche
haineuse ou en souffrance
haineuse et qu'on me dit que
l'immigration parce que en fait c'est
c'est ça beau n'être que la mousse
médiatique ça compte lorsqu'on entend
les seuls racisés entre guillemets je
n'aime pas ce terme mais utilisons-le
par convenance puisque il a été inscrit
dans le débat politique par la gauche
lorsqu'on entend les que les seuls
racisés qui ont l'autorisation de
s'exprimer à la télé vous dire que la
France est un pays affreux, que les
Français sont un peuple affreux. Mais
quand vous êtes français que vous prenez
ça, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Vous vous
dites "Mais en fait c'est des gens qui
sont ingrat.
Ça crée un repli identitaire.
Maintenant, moi ce que nous proposons en
conquête, c'est de faire l'inverse,
c'est-à-dire promouvons
à l'antenne, sur les médias, sur les
plateaux, des immigrations qui aiment la
France, des immigrations qui disent du
bien de la France. des immigrations qui
remercient la France. Quelle était ma
question ?
Qui expriment qui expriment leur
gratitude. La question sur votre ami là.
Non non, juste avant quand tu vois on a
discuté un peu ensemble, on a bu un coup
ensemble avant avant l'émission
arabe mais arabe de service c'est tout
on est tout à fait là-dedans. On est
tout à fait là-dedans. C'est-à-dire que
comme l'immigration haineuse de la
France est la seule qui est promue et
comme la haine de la France est le
marqueur idéologique de ce qui dirige la
France depuis 40 ans, il est évident que
si vous devenez français, vous devenez
quelque chose de mal.
Et on ne peut imaginer que l'idée que
vous êtes instrumentalisé par un système
haïable, par un pays haïable, au service
de ce pays haïable. Vous voyez ce que je
veux dire ? Donc c'est un c'est une il
faut pas simplement s'intéresser mais ça
je vous remercie je te remercie pour ta
question il ne faut pas s'intéresser à
la superficie épidermique du terme qui
est en ré qui est en réalité le pic de
l'iceberg de haine antifrançaise qui
nous dirige depuis une cinquantaine
d'années. Encore une fois un pays qui
est fier de lui-même, il considérerait
que des gens assimilés ne sont pas des
arabes de service. Il considérait que
des gens assez bien. Je vais vous donner
un exemple.
Tu
Oui. Non mais vous Non mais vous Non
mais vous collectivement
si tu me vous vois encore un coup, je
vais pisser.
Non c'est pas ça. C'est que je parle je
parle en même temps à tes
téléspectateurs qui sont très nombreux
là en ce moment. L'idée est simple. Euh
lorsque
en tant que français d'origine
étrangère, je m'adresse à la France et
je dis aux Français vous êtes un peuple
formidable. Vous avez fait de mois, il y
avait un accord tacite dans
l'immigration de l'assimilation telle
qu'elle se faisait jusqu'à la fin de
l'anné des années 70. Il y avait un
accord tacite. En gros, la France disait
à l'étranger,
fais ce que tu peux pour nous ressembler
identitairement et une fois que tu nous
ressembleras identitairement et
culturellement, tu deviendras un fils ou
une fille de France comme les autres.
C'est de ça dont j'ai bénéficié moi.
Vous voyez ? Et donc le problème c'est
que ce n'est plus possible avec
l'immigration invasion telle qu'elle a
démarré dans les années 80 avec le
regroupement familial. Moi, si vous
voulez, à l'égard de mon immigration, la
France fut extrêmement exigeante.
Vous croyez que c'est facile vous pour
un petit Égyptien qui vient d'arriver à
8 ans de lui demander de faire une
espèce de mu d'acculturation
pour devenir pour changer d'identité et
pour et pour être pour devenir
véritablement français ? Même si à la
fin, en ce en faisant cela, vous devenez
enfin la France vous déroule en quelque
sorte la France profonde, pas la France
du système antinational euh et de la
haine de la France qui est arrivée
après. Mais la France vous reconnaît.
Moi personnellement et je vous le dis
aujourd'hui euh presque en Scoupe, je
n'ai jamais été victime de racisme.
Pourquoi ? Parce que
parce que tu es beau gosse.
Parce que parce que je parle comme un
français. Je vis comme un français. Je
partage les valeurs de la France. Il y a
presque, vous savez, dans euh,
comment dire
dans dans dans le christianisme, il y a
une scène dans l'Évangile qui s'appelle
la transfiguration.
Et ben moi, je vais vous dire que quand
vous êtes pleinement assimilé à la
France, quelle que soit votre couleur de
peau, vous êtes comme transfiguré.
C'est-à-dire, on s'assoit sur votre
enveloppe charnelle qui dit que vous
venez de l'étranger, mais vous êtes
tellement français à l'intérieur de
vous-même. Vous savez, c'est la phrase
du général de Gaulle qui qui visite pour
la première fois les je crois que
c'était la la Martinique ou la
Guadeloupe, je ne sais plus, et qui est
accueilli par cette France
métropolitaine, belle de sa différence.
Euh et en fait les gens se précipitent
sur eux et la première phrase du général
de Gaulle, il les regarde, ils sont
évidemment noirs ou métisses. Et le
général de Gaulle dit "Mon Dieu, comme
vous êtes français !"
Il y a il y a l'identité française
lorsque elle vit en vous et c'est bien
ça la différence si vous voulez entre
des vrais français patriotes que nous
sommes et les macronistes, les
socialistes, les gauchistes. C'est que
pour ces gens-là, la France n'est qu'un
pays dans lequel ils habitent.
Faut pas dire gauchiste, tu es pas bien.
Je le dis.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est des gauchistes.
Tu t'es fait emmerder ? Tu t'es fait
harceler ? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi tu dis
moi j'ai on on a un principe ici c'est
pour ça
laisse-moi terminer je
t'en prie
euh
il y a trop de haine maintenant si on
narrive pas en France à trouver un
consensus pour avancer ensemble face à
la pieuvre des Russes, des Américains,
des mecs qui veulent nous faire la peau,
que ce soit au sein même de l'Union
européenne, il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver un consensus et qu'on se
réconcilie. Mais vous savez, c'est dis
pas dis pas gauchiste,
tu sais. C'est beaucoup moins insultant
d'être de dire gauchiste que de dire
fasciste ou dire extrémiste de droite ou
de dire. Nous, tu vois, on t'a invité
aujourd'hui parce que un, on trouve
marrant et cool, intelligent,
même si on n'est pas d'accord avec toi
sur certains trucs, on peut en parler
et ça c'est une grande qualité. Et on
t'a invité surtout parce qu'on avait
invité un communiste et il nous a dit
"Oui, non mais j'ai lu le dernier papier
qu'il y a eu sur vous sur BFM, vous êtes
des gens d'extrême droite. On a eu beau
lui dire que on est complètement à
politique et qu'on écoute tout le monde
parce qu'on essaie de trouver ce qu'il y
a le plus intéressant dans chacun et ça
nous a fait mal. Tu comp tu comptais
quand même pas te t'entendre tirer en
disant que tu étais neutre
parce que si tu es neutre si tu es pas
de gauche tu es d'extrême droite
pour la gauche c'est ça hein
et et en plus tu as fait une faute de
français et euh quand tu dis euh bah
ouais quand m'arrive
le peuple français je suis un vrai
français
le peuple français est formidable ça
c'est vrai que les français utilisent ça
mais est-ce que tu connais la la racine
du mot formidable formido qui veut dire
terrifiant
les gens ont poids en mode formidable
d'une façon inap approprié. Revenons à
ton parcours. Revenons à ta perception
de la France.
Revenons à nos moutons à l'al
commence pas à faire des blagues.
Le titre de l'émission c'est où va la
France ?
Jean, selon ta perception, ton
expérience, tes relations autour, ton
contact de terrain, ce que tu as vécu,
tu penses que notre pays va où ? Bah, si
j'étais euh optimiste, je dirais que la
France va dans le mur. Et si je suis
pessimiste, je dirais que la France
court à sa disparition.
Vous savez euh pourquoi je enfin vous
les téléspectateurs, hein, et toi euh
pourquoi je me suis engagé finalement
dans ce combat et de ce côté-ci du
spectre politique ?
C'est parce que
comme je t'ai dit, je suis un français
qui n'est pas né français.
Je suis arrivé en France à la fin des
années 70. La France était pour moi un
pays merveilleux, un pays
extraordinaire.
Euh beaucoup disaient que c'était une
exagération de dire qu'on est vivait
comme Dieu en France. Moi, je trouvais
c'était juste. À l'époque, on vivait
heureux comme Dieu en France.
Euh
et j'ai vu comme beaucoup de Français
d'ailleurs de souche et des Français de
branche, j'ai vu ce pays progressivement
disparaître.
disparaître
dans la population qui n'est plus la
même et infiner dans l'identité qui
n'est plus la même.
Et tu sais le problème c'est que
dans tous les combats politiques que
l'on peut mener, il y en a très peu
finalement qui sont irréversibles.
Je te donne un exemple. On nous dit la
priorité numéro 1, ça doit être le
pouvoir d'achat.
Le pouvoir d'achat, excuse-moi, une
politique des revenus pendant 2 3 ans, 4
ans, 5 ans peut rétablir le pouvoir
d'achat. C'est possible.
C'est possible. Une politique de
désendettement par rapport à à une dette
publiqueenne, c'est possible. Ça prendra
10 ans probablement, mais c'est
possible. On a vu des exemples de
désendettement spectaculaires après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale. L'Angleterre
notamment, on on parlera de ça une autre
fois, c'est possible. C'est pas
irréversible, je veux dire. Il le la
chute du poid d'achat n'est pas
irréversible. La désindustrialisation
n'est pas irréversible. On peut avoir
une politique industrielle qui
relocalise des activités, qui recrée des
filières. Je dis pas que ça peut être
fait du jour au lendemain, mais il y a
un horizon. C'est possible.
La seule chose qui est irréversible,
c'est lorsqu'un pays cesse d'être ce
qu'il est. Lorsqu'un pays perd son
identité, rien ni personne ne peut le
ramener. Tu me parlais en exergue à
cette émission de l'Égypte.
Est-ce que les gens se souviennent que
l'Égypte
en parlait, on en parlait ensemble parce
que je suis très attaché à l'Égypte. Je
sais,
tu m'as parlé, tu m'as tu m'as évoqué
des souvenirs émouvants. Euh,
on a anticipé les révolutions arabes et
on était parti en Égypte pour aller
repérer et se développer un réseau de
terrain pour être prévenu de l'évolution
des choses.
Et donc, on a parlé ensemble de l'Égypte
et à quel point j'ai été attaché à ce
peuple qui m'a reçu
et je les embrasse et je voilà,
l'Égypte, personne ne s'en souvient
aujourd'hui, mais l'Égypte a été copte
pendant 7 siècles. copte chrétien pens
chrétienne
chrétienne il y a eu un art copte il y a
eu une langue copte il y a eu une
administration copte lorsque les armées
arabo-musulmanes ont débarqué en Égypte
au 7e siècle
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous savez que
jusqu'au 14e siècle en Égypte la langue
copte était encore majoritaire
avec l'alphabet copte l'écriture copte
le problème c'est que
aujourd' aujourd'hui qui a souvenir
de la civilisation copte qui a pourtant
duré 6 siècles en Égypte avant que
l'Égypte ne devienne musulmane ? Est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un peut
ambitionner
de redonner vie à cette civilisation ?
C'est pas possible. Lorsqu'un pays cesse
d'être ce qu'il est, c'est définitif.
Donc il faut pas croire que la France
telle que nous l'avons connu et comme
serait comme immunisé de la disparition.
Pas du tout. Vous voyez bien
qu'aujourd'hui la France n'est plus que
l'ombre d'elle-même et n'est plus que
l'ombre de ce qu'elle a été
dans les années 70. Et en fait, mon
engagement, il provient de ce que la
chirurgie de guerre connaît très bien
qui s'appelle la douleur du membre
fantôme.
Tu sais ce que c'est la douleur du
membre fantôme ? Je connais très bien,
mes grands-parents se sont rencontrés à
l'hôpital des gueules cassé.
Et en terme de membres fantômes, les
terminaisons nerveuses.
Exactement. Ben moi, c'est pareil. Moi,
j'ai été assimilé à un pays
duquel je suis tombé profondément
amoureux tel qu'il était. J'ai pas envie
qu'il change en fait et j'ai pas envie
de qu'on m'explique que la France telle
qu'elle était était un mauvais pays.
Je peux me faire l'avocat du dial et que
et que c'est normal que ce pays change.
Donc j'éprouve un malaise identitaire
qui est sur le plan immatériel et
identitaire. Ce qu'éprouve un amputé, un
amputé
comme douleur du membre qu'il n'a plus.
Moi, le membre que je n'ai plus, c'est
cette France que j'ai chéri, que j'ai
aimé et dont je sens qu'elle est en
train de disparaître. Et ça me fait de
la peine. Ça me fait une douleur
indiscible. Et ça véritablement
ça définit,
comment dirais-je, la genèse de mon
combat politique. C'est pour faire en
sorte que la France reste ce qu'elle
est. Et lorsque j'ai écouté, j'ai
entendu Éric Zémour parler, nul mieux
que lui ne parle de cette douleur et de
ce malaise identitaire profond. Il faut
relire le succide français qui est un
livre lumineux.
Voilà, il a mis des mots mots sur les
mots mau que ressentent beaucoup de
Français. Et au départ, je me suis
engagé au RN. Le problème, c'est que le
RN a balancé par-dessus bord tout ce
croyait. Quand vous avez un parti
national qui vous dit que l'islam est
compatible avec la République, qui vous
dit que la politique de rémigration
c'est d'extrême droite, qui vous dit que
le grand remplacement c'est une théorie
complotique d'extrême droite, c'est en
fait voilà, c'est pas possible. Je
t'arrête une seconde. L'islam, regarde,
nous on a grandi euh dans mon quartier
les trois religions dominantes. C'est
les chrétiens, les juifs, les musulmans.
On allait manger la galette des rois
tous ensemble.
On allait on allait casser le Ramadan
pour aller se gaver de gâteau. On allait
faire les restes de Ranoua, aller
manger, ainsi de suite, les fêtes
juives, ainsi de suite. Bon,
je te pose la question, on va prendre
l'Égypte comme exemple. Avant c'était
les pharaons, bah les pharaons, ils ont
disparu. Ensuite il y a eu pharaon noir,
bon ils ont disparu. Il y a eu les
invasions euh de Nubi, il y a eu tout
ça. Bon, ça a changé. Est-ce que les
Égyptiens euh ils ont évolué ? Toi,
c'est ce qui te pose problème, c'est que
la France,
l'islam, elle est totalement compatible.
Regarde moi, mon pote, on faisait la
bouffe. Moi, je fais mes côtes de porc
pas dans la même poêle. Lui, il mange
pas ses côtes de porc pas dans la même
poêle. Qu'est-ce qui nous oblige à ça en
fait ?
Tout se respecte et ça voilà. Mais le
problème, si tu veux, c'est que
pourquoi la France serait-elle serait-il
le seul pays au monde où euh
regarde regarde Dubaï,
il picole les gens qui sont pieux, les
gens regarde les gens qui sont pieux
quand l'heure de la prière. Non mais la
question non mais je connais j'ai vécu
j'ai vécu je te dis j'ai vécu nous on
continua à boire notre v rouge
j'ai vécu aux Émir pendant 3 ans donc
vécu abou je fais l'avocat du diable le
mes potes ils reviennent ils ont fini
d'être pieux et de faire leur prière bon
et hop ça pose pas de problème.
Ben en fait ça pose pas de problème à
deux conditions.
La première condition, c'est que La
première condition, c'est que les le
nombre de musulmans reste minoritaire.
Majoritaire.
Non mais ici en France,
Ah oui,
ici en France, il faut que le nombre de
de musulmans reste minoritaires, reste
réduit à une portion congrue. C'est ce
que disait le général de Gaulle. Il sait
très bien qu'il y ait des gens qui
soient noirs, qui soient jaune, qui ait
des musulmans, qui soient français. Ça
prouve que la France est un pays ouvert,
que c'est un pays universel et cetera et
cetera. Mais rajout ajoutait-il,
il faut que ceci
euh restasse minoritaire
minoritaire jusqu'à faute de quoi ?
Quel est quel est le
faute de quoi la France ne serait plus
la France ?
Quel est le pourcentage maximum ?
Ben à partir vous savez euh chers
téléspectateurs que comme disait le
comme disait Lenine hein, c'est pas il
disait à partir d'un certain nombre la
quantité devient qualité.
Pourquoi ? Parce que vous voyez bien
dans vous voyez bien dans certains
quartiers ce qui se passe. Quand les
gens sont majoritairement installés dans
un quartier, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Vous avez plus d'alcool,
vous avez que des boucheries à l'alle,
vous n'avez plus de charcuterie et
cetera et cetera. Donc
évidemment qu'aujourd'hui la France de
part cette invasion migratoire et cette
islamisation,
pourquoi tu dis invasion ? Bah excuse
excuse-moi, mais quand tu as quand tu as
euh euh depuis une trentaine d'années
500000 personnes légales et illégales
qui arrivent en France,
c'est quoi les chiffres ? Ça vient d'où
? C'est quoi la source ?
Ah bah c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur. Euh euh il y a à peu près
renouvellements de enfin en tout cas
attribution de visa pour tout un tas de
raisons, d'études, de regroupement
familial, de et d'asile. L'asile, la
politique d'asile qui n'est plus une
politique d'asile, c'est devenu autre
filière d'immigration. Comment est-ce
possible que l'année dernière au titre
de l'asile, chiffre du ministère de
l'intérieur, on accueille plus de 150000
personnes au titre de l'asile politique
? L'asile politique en France a été
pensé pour des solles génicines.
On est supposé à travers cette filière
accueillir quelques dizaines de
personnes véritablement persécuté des
combattants de la liberté dans leur
pays. C'est pas fait pour accueillir une
population la population d'une grande
ville française. Et donc on voit bien
que le système qui qui dirige la France,
l'immigration n'est pas un problème,
c'est un projet.
On a peut-être besoin pour notre seuil
démographique.
Non.
Les Français font plus de gamin.
Alors, je je je je te l'explique très en
plus ça tombe bien que tu me poses cette
question parce que les chiffres viennent
de tomber hier. les chiffres de LINEC
euh tu as un taux un taux de de
fécondité français de 1,6 1,56 enfants
par femme.
Pour l'affaire courte,
vous avez donc
156 enfants pour 1000 femmes.
C'est un taux historiquement bas. C'est
le taux de fécondité français le plus
faible.
depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale
et certains disent même que c'est le
plus faible depuis 1918. C'est dire
jusqu'à présent, en terme démographique,
la France avait tiré son épingle du jeu.
On était il y a il y a encore 5 ou 6 ans
très proche du seuil de renouvellement
des générations qui est de 2,1 enfants
par femme. Aujourd'hui, on est à 1,56.
Mais ce chiffre en fait, c'est un
chiffre en trompleœuil parce que ce
qu'on vous dit pas, c'est que à
l'intérieur de cette moyenne, le taux de
fécondité
des femmes
issues de l'immigration
est beaucoup plus important.
On est à 2.16
enfants par femme contre, je répète 1,6
de moyenne nationale. C'est-à-dire que
le taux de fécondité des natives
françaises
est beaucoup plus faible en réalité.
Et en fait, c'est une illusion d'optique
qui va être instrumentalisée
par le système antinational qui nous
dirige. Parce que qu'est-ce qu'il va
vous dire ? il va vous dire, vous voyez,
la natalité française, la démographie
française est très peu dynamique. Nous
avons très peu d'enfants par femme et
c'est un un record historiquement bas,
sans jamais vous évoquer que le taux de
fécondité des femmes immigrées est très
important, ça il va le cacher. Et sur la
base du taux de fécondité d'un 56
chiffre IN, il va vous dire la meilleure
manière de lutter contre le déficit
démographique français
c'est de faire venir des immigrés. Ça
pose deux questions. La première, c'est
que quand vous avez une démographie
immigrée qui est beaucoup plus
dynamique,
faire venir d'autres immigrés ne pourra
que dynamiser la démographie des
immigrés puisque vous en vous en
importez, sans pour autant apporter une
réponse
au taux de fécondité historiquement bas
des Français de souche.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Jean,
regarde-toi, tu es tu es papa de 18
enfants.
Combien tu as d'enfants ?
19.
Non, j'en ai j'en ai
Donc tu tu nous as fait des petits
français.
Oui.
Et donc je me mets je je vais défendre
le politique. Je je fais l'avocat du
diable même si j'y crois pas une seule
seconde, mais je suis obligé. Ils se
disent voilà on fait venir des immigrés,
ils vont s'intégrer comme toi.
Mais non mais parce que c'est mais tu
vois bien
et attends laisse-moi terminer
laisse-moi. Je je grossis le trait
exprès.
Et donc ils se disent "Bon bah il va ils
vont nous faire des petits français.
Oui, mais si leurs parents sont pas
eux-mêmes français, comment ils vont
accoucher de français ? Ils sont
naturalisés donc ils deviennent français
et puis que
Ah mais attendez alors ça alors ça c'est
très intéressant euh
parce que tu me fais tu me fais mettre
le point le doigt sur un point
extrêmement intéressant, c'est que
on parle beaucoup de la politique
d'immigration délirante. Je crois que
maintenant ça fait consensus au sein de
la d'une majorité de Français. Mais ce
dont on oublie de parler très souvent,
qu'en fait les Français ne connaissent
pas, c'est la tout aussi délirante
politique de naturalisation.
Cette politique de naturellation qui
naguer réservait la nationalité
française
à des gens dont la trajectoire
d'assimilation
était parfaitement achevée, testé,
vérifié, c'est d'ailleurs dans le code
civil, nul ne peut être naturalisé que
s'il a été assimilé à la France. On a
fait sauter cette règle
pour naturaliser en fait des Français à
la chaîne sans aucune vérification d'une
quelconque assimilation à la France.
Parce qu'un système qui dit que la
France a été un pays abominable et
qu'aux olympiades de l'horreur, la
France a toujours été en première place
sur le podium, on peut pas demander à
l'immigré de s'assimilier à ses
horreurs. Donc la politique de
naturalisation devient en réalité une
politique de contrefaçon identitaire.
C'est-à-dire que quand vousisez
quelqu'un et moi j'en connais, je
connais même des Égyptiens qui ont été
naturalisés français alors même qu'il ne
savait pas parler français
et je peux vous les montrer.
Il savaient peut-être cuisiner le
bourguignon.
Bah non, même pas. Cuisiner la moloya si
tu veux. Mais mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vousisez
français des gens qui n'ont pas qui ne
se sont pas acculturés à la France ? Ce
sont des gens qui vont facialement
avoir la nationalité française au sens
administratif du terme,
mais ils n'en ont ni l'allégance,
ni la culture, ni l'identité.
Exemple très simple. Qu'est-ce qui
démontre aujourd'hui que tu es français
? Comment tu prouves l'idée que tu es
français ? Ça, ça c'est très simple. Le
document, il s'appelle comment ? Quand
un flic te te t'arrête, il te dit "Je
veux voir votre
carte.
national d'identité
et moi je lui dis on est plus sous
Vichi.
Non non non mais tu écoutes les tu
est-ce que tu entends les mots ont un
sens la le document qui te permet
d'attester
de ta citoyenneté s'appelle comment ?
Une carte nationale d'identité.
On l'oublie ça. C'est pas qu'une carte.
Cette carte est censée recouvrir un bout
de la nation et l'identité qui lui est
liée.
Or, cette politique
de distribution de la naturelle à des
gens qui ne sont objectivement pas
d'identité française a abouti à un
éclatement de ce triptique qui à
l'origine est un triptique
consubstantiel. On ne sépare pas la
carte de la nation et de l'identité. Ça
s'appelle une carte nationale
d'identité. Sauf qu'aujourd'hui,
on a créé en fait des faux français un
peu comme on fabrique de la fausse
monnaie. C'est horrible de dire ça.
Non, c'est vrai aujourd'hui
pour toi
mais pas pour moi. Quand alors
regarde mon pote, mon pote marocain,
je vais te dire quand les gens
tu crois que mon pote marocain c'est un
faux français.
Oui.
Pourquoi ?
Est-ce que quand lui te tu lui demandes
de de se définir se définit comme
français ?
Bah bien entendu.
Mais non, tu me dis qu'il a fait son
business au Maroc. Ah bah parce qu'il
s'est fait il s'est fait emmerder toute
sa jeunesse qu'ait plein de cul.
Donc il peut pas se définir comme étant
un citoyen d'un pays qui l'a emmerdé. On
peut être d'accord làdessus.
Définit toujours français hein. C'estd
que lui c'est
pourquoi il est mao ?
Bah si tu me dis que d'un côté
il été contaminé par la France
d'un côté tu me dis que la il estime que
la France s'est très mal comportée avec
lui.
Vo quand je le vois je lui dis fo gras
sa te manque pas un petit peu ? Il me
dit il y a tout ce qu'il faut à Dubaï
mais je lui dis noir de bigor il me dit
non je mange pas de porc je lu dis bah
tu sais pas ce que tu loupes mon pote.
Mais ça reste un français.
Bah je je pour moi un français c'est
celui qui porte sa francité en
bandoulière. Je ne comprends pas comment
en France tu peux porter tes origines en
bandoulière.
En France tu as le droit d'être fier
d'être marocain. Je
t'ouvre une
fier d'être fier d'être algérien, d'être
fier d'être tunisien.
Oui. Fier d'être français. Regarde, on
était à Dubaï là, c'était il y a un an
et demi ou 2 ans, demi-finale de je sais
pas quoi de football, c'était la France
contre je sais pas quoi, je crois le
Portugal ou un truc comme ça. Et ben
nous, on était côté français. Bon, je
déteste le foot. Si ça avait été du
rugby, on serait marré.
Et si la France jouait contre le Maroc,
il aurait soutenu qui ?
Ah bah là, on parlait sur les deux là,
c'est ça la question.
Bah, on parlait sur les deux. Je pense
qu'il aurait défendu la France en
premier. Si la France jouait contre le
Maroc, il aurait défendu qui ? Ça c'est
la toute la question.
Je l'appelle. Tu veux que je l'appelle ?
appelle-le.
Mais moi je je encore une fois moi
j'adorerais que les gens tous les gens
qui ont portent la nationalité française
emporte l'identité et soient fier de
l'être. Mais tu peux quand même convenir
avec moi qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des
ce que j'appelle des millions de
français contrefait, c'est-à-dire des
gens qui ont été ta source des millions
là, tu as été faire un recensement. Toi
tu es français, tu penses que tu es
français, tu es pas français.
Mais attends, ça fait 50 ans que nous
vivons 50 ans que nous vivons avec une
politique d'immigration délirante, une
politique de haine de la France. Tu
sais, tout a commencé en 1983
par cette constitution
philosophico-politique qui irrigue
toutes les arcane du pouvoir qui est le
bouquin de Bernard Henry Lévi qui
s'appelle l'idéologie française.
Quand tu lis ce livre qui je te le dis,
ce livre, l'idéologie française est la
constitution de tout le système
politique qui dirige la France depuis
une cinquantaine d'années. Ce livre est
un immondice antifrançais. Non, il faut
pas dire immondice.
Si je le prends, ça
c'est un ça reste un livre.
Mais quand il dit quand Bernard Henri
Lévi dit "J'ai toujours eu en horreur
les binous, les franchouillards et
cetera" et qu'il injurit le peuple
français. Le moins qu'on le moins qu'on
puisse dire, c'est que moi je considère
que cees propos, ce livre est un
immondisme parce que c'est ce sont des
immondises que Bernard Henry Lévit dit
sur la France et qui sont repris. C'est
ça le pire. Et moi je te dis je suis
français qu'il puisse dire des des
conneries sur les binou Queenaman ou sur
le noir de Bigor ou sur le le bœuf
Bourguignon ou sur quoi que ce soit. Moi
je le regarde, je lui dis "Mais OK, tu
es en France, tu dis ce que tu veux, tu
écris ce que tu veux."
Dans ce cas-là, j'ai le droit de dire ce
que je veux aussi
dans un livre. Et
non mais les médias c'est un livre à
cœur, c'est un livre ouvert.
Et je lui dis "Bah reste dans ton coin,
moi je vais aller jouer du bou avec mes
potes, on va aller boire du chouchen."
Mais c'est pareil. Mais une fois Non,
mais une fois que j'ai dit que le le
bouquin de Bernard Henri Lévi est un
immondiste, tu as le droit d'aller le
lire, hein. C'est pas
Mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Euh euh ça
c'est
Et donc le problème, si tu veux, il est
là, c'est que euh
on en fait l'immigration
n'a jamais été, en tout cas depuis les
années 80 une chance pour la France.
Depuis les années 80, l'immigration est
en réalité une chance pour ceux qui
haïsent la France, pas pour la France.
On a instrumentalisé l'immigration.
Le système dirigeant la France qui est
la France et qui infini veut en finir
avec la France instrumentalise
l'immigration pour accélérer
l'euthanasie de la France.
Voilà ce qui se passe. Et donc
on a aujourd'hui des gens qui en raison
du droit du sol, d'une politique
migratoire délirante, d'une politique de
de naturalisation tout aussi délirante,
nous avons créé des peuples dans le
peuple, c'est-à-dire des gens qui
portent la nationalité française mais
qui n'ont en réalité rien à voir avec la
France. des gens qui sont facialement au
sens administratif du terme français
mais qui n'ont pas l'identité française,
qui n'ont pas d'allégance à la nation
française et qui au contraire
nourrissent à l'égard de la France un
irrédantisme revanchard
qu'il traduisent d'ailleurs dans les
comportements que vous voyez d'agression
individuelle des Français au jour le
jour.
Bon,
ton constat, quelles sont les solutions
? Parce que soulever un problème, il
faut peut-être apporter des solutions.
Si si tu veux, les solutions, ce sont
les solutions de reconquête. C'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai rejoint euh
ce parti il y a maintenant 2 ans, 3 ans.
Euh il est simple. Déjà, la première
chose, c'est arrêter l'immigration
tout de suite. Une immigration zéro. Tu
fais comment ? Tu tu mets tu fais des
murs, tu mets des barbelés, tu mirador,
on rétablit les frontières que comment
font les autres pays qui n'ont pas
d'immigration chez eux ? Je moi j'en ai
j'en ai vraiment et là j'en profite pour
pousser un coup de gueule, j'en ai
vraiment mais ras la casquette des gens
qui vous des gens dont la seule
politique c'est l'impossibilisme.
Dès que tu veux faire quelque chose, on
te dit "Ah bah c'est pas possible,
immigration zéro, c'est pas possible."
Alors, j'entends bien sûr qu'on pourra
jamais empêcher
le moindre migrant illégal de traverser
la frontière. Mais on peut quand même
convenir qu'entre l'immigration
délirante d'aujourd'hui et l'immigration
nulle à zéro, nous avons quand même des
marges appréciables de progrès. On peut
être d'accord là-dessus. Bon, lorsque
Donald Trump a été élu sur la promesse
de réduire drastiquement l'immigration
et de renvoyer les clandestins,
évidemment que quand il lance un combat,
il n'est pas sûr de le gagner. Les gens
ont beau jeu dira mais il réussira
jamais, même avec des murs et cetera,
c'est pas possible. D'accord. Mais je
veux dire, les combats qu'on est s de
perdre, comme disait le général de Gaul,
sont ceux que l'on mène pas. Mener un
combat ne garantit pas de le gagner,
mais se contenter en tant que politique
de dire que rien n'est faisable, que
rien n'est possible, bah c'est la
meilleure façon de ne rien faire. Et
c'est ce à quoi nous assistons depuis
maintenant 40 ans.
Question internet que je viens de voir
dans mon champ de vision latéral.
D'ailleurs, que pensent-il de l'ICE aux
USA ? C'est
Bah, c'est ce que je vais y venir. Je
pense que donc premièrement, il faut
arrêter toute immigration officielle.
Tu manges du porc toi ? Bien sûr. Et je
vais et je vais te choquer. Je bois même
de l'alcool,
ça je sais ça.
Euh un il faut arrêter toute migration
officielle.
Tu mangeais du porc quand tu étais en
Égypte ?
Oui.
Tu es copte ?
Oui. Il y a des chrétiens qui vendent du
porc en Égypte donc j'en mange
qui vendent des clopes.
Alors je te coupe parce que bon ça me
fait tellement plaisir d'avoir un un
ancien égyptien parce que tu es ancien
égyptien.
Un français né en Égypte. Oui.
Voilà.
Un jour, un soir, un dimanche, plus de
clope en Égypte,
je vais voir mes potes. Je dis les gars,
il faut que je trouve des clopes là. Ils
me disent "Bah pas de problème, tu vas
voir le chrétien, il est 22h, il est
toujours ouvert,
il vend des clopes."
Et moi ça m'a fait penser en France,
nous on appelait c'est notre épicerie
arabe du coin
des clopes et ainsi de suite.
Mais tu vois, ça avait c'était inversé
parce que maintenant les copes ils sont
relégués à à tenir des petites épiceries
dans le sud de l'Égypte. Je sais pas
comment c'est.
Ben en fait les les copes tu les
retrouves parmi les très riches, peu
nombreux
ou les très pauvres
ou les très pauvres. Moi, j'ai pas envie
que les Français deviennent ça dans leur
propre pays.
Allez, continue laiss.
Euh donc premièrement, arrêt total de
l'immigration. Et la deuxième chose,
c'est que pour l'immigration qui est
déjà en France, qui est quand même assez
massive, le ministre de l'intérieur,
monsieur Nunz, a récemment reconnu de
dans une interview qu'il a accordé à
Sonia Mabrou sur ses news qu'il n'y
avait pas moins de 700000 immigrés
clandestins en France. Il a reconnu le
chiffre. La plupart des spécialistes
s'entend entre 700000 et 1 million.
Évidemment, comme c'est une immigration
clandestine, on peut pas la quantifier
avec précision, mais que lorsque le
ministre de l'intérieur dit qu'on est à
peu près à 700000, moi j'ai tendance à
le croire bizarrement. Bon euh bah il
faut évidemment que ces gens-là
réémigrent.
On peut pas avoir 700000 personnes
illégales. Non seulement aujourd'hui le
système en place en France ne les
rémigre pas, mais il leur donne des
soins gratuits et tout un tas d'aides
gratuits à travers l'AME, à travers une
petite aide au logement et cetera et
cetera. Tu autoriser à te couper gens ?
Ouais.
Ces gens-là, ils sont là depuis combien
de temps ?
Mais peu importe.
Attends, laisse-moi terminer. Ces
gens-là, ils sont là depuis combien de
temps ? Depuis longtemps, pas longtemps,
très longtemps,
peu importe. On peut pas le savoir de
toute façon. Ce sont des illégaux.
Imagine-toi si ça fait 5 6 7 ans qu'ils
sont là, ils bossent. Alors que ce soit
au black ou pour
il devrait pas bosser, c'est illégal. Il
faut bien survivre.
Ils sont ils sont peut-être en voie
d'assimilation à essayer de de
C'est extraordinaire. Laisse-moi,
laisse-moi terminer. Laisse-moi
terminer.
Ouais, je t'écoute. Je t'écoute.
Tu vas les renvoyer dans un pays bah
qu'ils ont désapris.
Non,
ils vont être tristes.
S'il reste en France, c'est que c'est
toujours un peu meilleur que là d'où ils
sont partis.
Alors, de deux choses.
Est-ce qu' est-ce que il faut pas leur
tendre un peu plus la main ?
La première chose,
le tendre la main différemment.
La première chose, alors j'ai plusieurs
réponses à cela.
La première chose, c'est que
évidemment que moi, si j'étais si je
vivais dans un pays où je crève la fin,
où j'ai pas de perspective, où ma
famille souffre, moi je
non plus jusqu'à la moelle,
ben je je ne je ne reproche pas en fait
à ces je n'ai rien contre eux. C'est
tout à fait humain que ces gens
cherchent à avoir un avenir meilleur.
Sauf que moi, étant français,
ma priorité c'est de m'intéresser à
l'intérêt des Français.
Quand vous avez un pays qui a 3300
milliards d'euros de dette publique,
quand vous avez un pays où la croissance
endémique
est à ton
pays où toute catégorie de chômage
confondu, on dépasse les 5 millions.
Je n'ai pas l'impression spontanément à
la lecture de ce tableau que ce pays
dispose de moyens oisasifs
permettant de faire une charité. Moi, je
n'ai rien contre la charité. Je suis
chrétien pratiquant.
J'ai pas j'ai bien sûr qu'il faut aider
son prochain et qu'il faut
tu vas pas à la messe en latin
et qu'il faut lui je vais à la messe en
copte. ce qui est ce qui est
euh je n'ai pas de problème avec ça.
Sauf que charité vous est-ce que tu sais
que c'est même pas chrétien, c'est
musulman.
Et il y a il y a un proverbe en Égypte,
je sais pas si tu le connais, en arabe
c'est
dit en français. Ça veut dire que ce qui
ce que ce que Allah proclame halal pour
ta maison devient haram pour la mosquée.
C'estàd que si tes moyens
sont à peine suffisants pour les tiens,
Allah déclare que c'est haram. Donc
interdit que tu les files à la mosquée.
Et
comment tu traduis ? parce que
en fait ces charités bien ordonnées
commencent par soi. C'est c'est une un
corollaire ou une variante si tu veux.
C'estd que si ta famille, ta femme, tes
enfants, ta famille proche a besoin de
l'intégralité des ressources parce que
il suffisent à peine à couvrir tes
besoins, tu n'as pas le droit en tant
que musulman de retirer ce dont ta
famille a besoin pour faire l'omone à la
mosquée. Donc c'est universel en fait.
Jamais aucun pays arabo-musulman ne
retirera de la bouche de ses enfants
pour donner à la bouche d'étranger.
Alors, qu'est-ce que tu préconises
concrètement ?
Concrètement donc je te disais l'arrêt
immédiat de l'immigration et pour
l'immigration massive déjà présente en
France reconquête et le seul parti qui
comme d'ailleurs aux États-Unis, tu m'as
posé la question sur ICE, propose la
rémigration. la rémigration parce que ça
c'est un mot qui est générique et qui
peut faire peur, je vais l'expliquer et
le décortiquer.
En réalité, c'est par cercle
concentrique. Déjà, le premier cercle
concentrique périphérique, c'est la
masse des immigrés illégaux.
Tu me disais "Mais ces gens sont là
depuis 5 6 ans et cetera en gros." Mais
est-ce que tu t'imagines ce que tu es en
train de me dire ? C'est comme si demain
nous disions "Bah après tout, tu as un
mec qui conduit sans permis depuis 10
ans."
Bah régularisons-le.
Il a échappé à tous les contrôles. Il
conduit bien, il conduit sans permis.
Donnons-lui le permis
peut-être. Faisons-lui passer le permis.
Ou alors Ou alors pire quelqu'un qui a
fraudé le fisque
et qui ne s'est pas fait arrêter, qui ne
s'est pas fait choper. Bon bah très
bien. Ben dans ce cas-là, faisons-li
cadeau de tout.
Alors mais
on peut pas il peut pas y avoir de prime
à l'illégalité si tu veux ni dans le
domaine de l'immigration. Ton
premier exemple
ni dans le domaine des autres. Ton
premier exemple, le mec qui roule sans
permis, bon bah si c'est un chauffard,
OK, mais il roule sans permis parce que
il s'est tapé peut-être 5 6 7 de vitesse
à 2 kmh près, il a perdu un point de
laisse-moi terminer, je suis d'accord
avec toi, c'est la loi.
Bon, il se fait guler,
il se fait contrôler, le véhicule se
fait immobiliser. Là, tu as deux
solutions.
Soit tu dis, tu passes ton permis, soit
tu dégages.
Si les émigrés sans papier sont
attrapés, pourquoi pas leur proposer un
test pour voir si ils sont assimilés ?
Ils ont essayé par tous les moyens de
s'assimiler. Qu'est-ce que tu en penses
de ça ?
Non, parce que je trouve que c'est donné
encore une fois une prime à la clandie.
Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce que Quel signal
tu envoies ? tuenvoie un signal au aux
demilliards de personnes qui sont
candidates à venir s'installer en
Occident de manière générale et et
singulièrement en France en leur disant
"Les gars, si vous venez, que vous êtes
fut, que vous arrivez à rentrer
clandestinement, à échapper à tous les
contrôles, à vous maintenir sur le
territoire, vous aurez une chance un
jour d'être régularisé."
Et moi si je te chope, je te dis voilà
alors comment ça se passe ? Est-ce que
tu as élevé correctement tes enfants ?
Est-ce que tes enfants vont à l'école ?
Est-ce qu'il parlent correctement ?
Laisse-moi te
Mais c'est prévu.
Est-ce que est-ce que tout ça est-ce que
ta femme tu la tu la respectes, elle
travaille ? Tu es gam travail, ils vont
à l'école. C'est prévu.
Bon toi
si tu es si tu es un père maltraitant
tu as l'aide sociale à l'enfance. Si le
gars si le gars si le gars il se
comporte bien, il travaille
et on lui fait passer le test de
français euh
et ça se passe bien si ça fait plus de
10 ans qu'il est en France qu'il a vécu
pendant dans la peur pendant 10 ans
parce que à se faire choper par les
flics et avoir un OQTF de se faire
emmerder. Bon là il se fait choper. Tu
lui fais passer son test de français, tu
tu fais un examen de sa vie et peut-être
qu'il mérite d'être français parce que
en fait il est peut-être plus français
que beaucoup de français. Qu'est-ce que
tu en penses Non, moi je pense qu'il
faut d'abord le renvoyé.
Je je je pense qu'il faut d'abord le
problème n'est pas pour le coup un
problème d'individualité. C'est aussi le
signal que tu renvoies parce que je vais
te poser un tu m'as prends l'exemple de
ICE, la politique de Donald Trump qui
vise à rémigrer les immigrés
clandestins.
D'abord évidemment elle rémigre ceux
qu'ils arrêtent et qu'ils mettent dans
un avion. Donc ça c'est le premier moule
de personnes renvoyées chez eux.
Ensuite, les images de rémigration font
que tu as certains clandestins qui se
disent "J'ai pas envie d'être arrêté et
de subir ce sort là." Donc, tu as des
départs volontaires et tu as surtout
aussi les gens qui voient ces images à
l'étranger et qui se disent "Mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux que j'aille faire
dans cette dans ce bordel ?" En fait, je
préfère ne pas bouger et rester là où
j'en suis.
Donc c'est ça qu'on veut obtenir. C'est
non seulement l'effet direct mais aussi
le les signaux qu'on envoie vis-à-vis de
l'étranger.
OK. Si les pays en question dont ils
sont d'originaire disent "Bon, tu es
bien gentil gens mais nous on en veut
pas parce que c'est des délinquants, ils
sont très bien chez toi. Nous on en veut
plus chez nous. Ils sont partis du pays
donc ils ont été traître à leur propre
patrie. Et ben tu les gardes, qu'est-ce
que tu fais ? Aucun aucune personne qui
rentre sur légal illégalement sur le
territoire français ne doit être
autorisée à s'y maintenir.
D'accord. Mais si le pays euh des
migrations,
ben dans ce cas-là, il faut que dans les
ambassades, dans les consulats, on
puisse déposer des dossiers euh voilà de
de d'asile, mais c'est vrai que quand
ils arrivent une fois qu'ils sont en
France, on ne peut plus les renvoyer
chez eux. Voilà, c'est tout.
Tu fais comment ? Ben,
on les renvoie chez eux. On les renvoie
dans un pays tiers par exemple. C'est ce
que tu es en train de faire la
Grande-Bretagne.
Ouais. Non mais la Grande-Bretagne, il
faut pas se comparer au derniers de la
classe. Tu imagines renvoyer dans un
pays tiers, ils veulent les mettre au
quoi ? Au Kenya, c'est ça ? Non,
en Rwanda.
Rwanda.
Euh,
tu te rends compte ?
Je peux je peux j'ai une petite urgence.
Je peux prendre une pause ou pas ?
Non. Tu as envie de pisser, je t'accorde
une pause. Tu sais où c'est ?
Oui. 5 minutes.
Vas-y. Donc pas 5 minutes. 2 minutes. Tu
prends ton micro, tu le mets dans la
poche, tu coupes le micro pour éviter
qu'on entende le gens pisser. Et moi,
moi je vais faire la causette à notre
communauté. Je t'avais dit de pas
picoler, mec.
Tiens, vas-y. Vas-y. Donc pendant
pendant que Jean est est parti, on va en
profiter pour dire "Soutenez-nous sur
Tipi, on a besoin de vous parce que euh
c'est quand même une grosse
infrastructure, c'est beaucoup de
connaissances. On bosse, on bosse, on
bosse et on sera très heureux un jour de
faire une interview avec les questions
de la communauté
pour répondre à à toutes vos requêtes,
vos questions, vos doutes ou vos
suggestions de d'interview, d'invités.
Euh quel débat vous a le plus plu ? Quel
sujet vous a le plus ? D'ailleurs, on
propose à la communauté qui est sur le
le chat de nous envoyer des questions et
de les faire monter une par une en en en
notant avec un petit pouce vers le haup
comme ça quand Jean va revenir de son
petit pipi, on va pouvoir euh poser
directement vos questions et et il faut
battre le fer pendant qu'il est encore
chaud. Euh alors pour tout vous dire,
juste avant l'émission, on lui a fait
boire quatre cafés et un petit verre de
blanc. Et donc bon, Jean avec si ça
arrive de temps en temps qu'un invité
euh nous nous fasse un petit pi. Ça ça
nous est d'ailleurs aussi arrivé. Donc
on va on va lire les questions qu'on va
commencer à lui poser. Faire une
démarche de naturalisation est un vrai
engagement civique et citoyen. Le droit
du sol donne une légitimité d'un
territoire mais nullement de l'histoire
de pays. La culture reste maternelle.
Quelle est sa vision sur ce point ? On
va aussi lui poser ça. On va remonter un
peu un peu le fil de questions.
Était à Ice. On va lui poser les
questions s'il est au courant que la FMA
euh a fait quelques camps de rétention
administrative avec des barbelets qui
vont pas vers l'extérieur mais qui vont
vers l'intérieur pour empêcher les gens
de sortir. Il faut aussi parler de la
misère humaine des des migrations, les
migrations économiques qui sont aussi
provoquées par des États qui pilent les
ressources euh des pays qui nous
envoient des gens qui sont en grande
souffrance aussi. Question internet,
pourquoi l'immigration est l'intérêt
primordial de Jean Messias ? Ça, on va
lui poser. Manger, boire, dormir, loger
sont des intérêts que Jean ignore.
Pourquoi ? Pas interrogation. Attendez,
bougez pas, je vais appeler Jean. Jean,
dépêche-toi.
On va Ouais, ouais. Bah les gens, il
doit avoir une vessie de 55 cll. C'est
c'est Ensuite, on va lui poser une autre
question. A-t-il conscience de
l'incompétence de Trump ? Ça, on va lui
aussi lui poser la question. Vu de ses
compétences en économie, peut-il nous
parler du boomerisme ? Le concept de
pomper toujours plus les actifs pour
donner toujours plus au vieux. Ça, on va
lui poser aussi comme question. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous noter les questions
sur le chat entre vous pour qu'on puisse
lui poser directement ? Ah, Jean est de
retour.
Jean ?
Ouais. Dis donc, c'était un gros pipi
lui aussi, hein.
La semaine prochaine, alors on va vous
donner deux deux scoupes. Euh on est en
train de négocier euh trois ambassades
en ce moment. Alors, on vous expliquera
comment on négocie une interview avec un
ambassadeur quand on appelle
l'ambassade.
Il y a Jean qui est en train de marcher
de loin.
Le c'était un grand verre de blanc.
C'était une tulipe de blanc. Je crois
que c'était Alors, il nous a demandé un
verre de blanc léger.
Mais
moi je veux bien faire la speaker gens
mais ça va 5 minutes hein. Donc
non mais il est en train de remettre sa
la valière là ou quoi ?
Magnifique. On entend sa douce démarche.
Magnifique. Allez, tu t'es lavé les
mains ?
Oui.
Magnifique.
Ah, j'aime quand tu m'appelles papa.
Donc revenons à Ice. Oui.
Donc I quand est-ce que tu es au courant
que la FEMA fait des camps de rétention
administratif avec depuis un certain
nombre d'années
un peu à l'image d'ailleurs des camps
qu'il y a eu pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale avec les Japonais ? Non mais ça
je réfute ces comparaisons parce que
le problème si tu veux c'est que nous
avons nous sommes comme tétanisés
par ce que j'appelle l'effet
distéritarismes des 20e siècles.
Oui mais c'est ici c'est comme à la
maison donc
c'est naturel.
Nous sommes tétanisés par l'effet
distérèse des totalitarismes du 20e
siècle. En gros,
tu n'as pas, par exemple, tu n'as pas le
droit d'être patriote parce que tu
comprends Hitler était patriote et
Mussolini était patriote.
Donc si tu es patriote, non mais je je
viens à ta question, je vais juste
en France, tu as le droit d'être
patriote.
Tu as pas le droit, tu es d'extrême
droite.
Bah non, tuas il y a une grande
différence,
c'est pire que ça aujourd'hui. Droite,
c'est juste être français en fait. Il y
a une grande différence entre y a une
grande différence entre nationaliste et
patriote.
Peu importe, mais ils sont même plus
là-dedans. Aujourd'hui, je te le dis, le
simple fait que tu sois français et que
tu veuilles le rester te définit comme
quelqu'un d'extrême droite. Aujourd'hui,
être raciste, c'est juste refuser que
ton pays devienne africain.
Être islamophobe, c'est juste refuser
que la France devienne un pays musulman.
On en est plus là.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons un débat qui est
interdit. Tu es bien placé pour le
savoir. Nous avons une interdiction du
débat. Je te parle même pas de l'humour,
hein. Les gens comme le Luron, Coluche,
Michel Leb, il serait en tôle
aujourd'hui.
Voilà. Aujourd'hui, nous sommes, il y a
la une chappe de plomb qui s'est abattu,
un rideau de fer qui s'est abattu sur la
liberté d'expression et qui fait que en
gros on a criminalisé, pénalisé
toute forme de conscience nationale,
toute forme d'expression de l'identité
nationale et toute forme de résistance.
a une tentative de conquête et de
domination altère identitaire.
Voilà. Donc si tu refuses que la France
devienne un pays musulman, tu es
islamophobe. Ah bah d'accord, donc je
OK, donc comme je veux pas être
islamophobe, pas de problème. La France
peut être un pays musulman.
Tu refuses une invasion de la France par
l'Afrique, mais tu es raciste.
Ah bah non, je suis pas raciste. Alors
bon, donc tu acceptes l'invasion ? Ah
d'accord, OK, j'accepte l'invasion.
C'est comme ça que ça se passe. Comment
ça tu veux être français et rester
français ? Mais tu es un haineux, tu es
d'extrême droite.
C'est comme ça que ça se passe. Ah non,
ben non, mais moi je suis pas une
d'extrême droite. Ah ouais, bah pas de
problème. Alors, ouvrez les frontières
et faites venir tout le monde. Voilà
comment fonctionne le système depuis une
cinquantaine d'années. Et c'est
d'ailleurs les résultats sont visibles à
l'œil nu pour l'ensemble des Français
qui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs sont majorita
majoritairement contre. C'est pour ça,
c'est pour ça que un peu partout en
Europe, tu vois des mouvements
identitaires ou de repli identitaire.
C'est pas de repli, c'est au contraire,
c'est de réappropriation identitaire,
c'est pas de repli. Ce sont des gens qui
se disent "Moi, j'en ai strictement rien
à de me faire traiter de
d'extrémistes de droite, de fasciste, de
haineux, d'islamophobes, de raciste. Je
suis ce que je suis et je veux rester ce
que je suis chez moi."
Et si vous n'êtes pas content, c'est
pareil.
Voilà. Voilà intrinsèquement ce que
signifient les votes pour des partis
identitaires
et nationaux en Europe. Ce sont des
gens, des électeurs, des citoyens qui en
ont marre d'être acculés dans une forme
de honte de ce qu'ils sont. Mais en
fait, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? C'est
nous, nous ne sommes pas haineux. Quand
tu défends l'idée que tu dois que tu es
français et que tu veux rester français
en France, tu es personne à ce
moment-là. Tu dis juste à ceux qui
viennent que si ils veulent rester en
France, bah un, ils deviennent s'ils
deviennent français, ils doivent avoir
l'identité française et de à tout le
moins de pouvoir respecter les lois, les
règles, les civilités françaises. Mais
lorsque quelqu'un te dit "Ben dire ça,
fais de toi un extrémiste, c'est pas moi
l'extrémiste." Jusqu'à nouvel ordre,
nous sommes en France. Donc c'est normal
qu'en France, on soit français. En fait,
on en est là. Le truc, ce qu'on vit est
tellement délirant qu'on en vient à euh
transformer l'étruisme
en propos révolutionnaire.
Oui, je suis on est en France, je suis
français et je veux rester français.
C'est un truisme mais c'est inaudible
pour toute une partie du système qui
rien que le fait que tu énonces
une pareille la palissade fait de toi un
nazi.
D'accord ? En réalité, ce sont un
certain nombre de minorités
suprémacistes qui elles sont
francophobes.
Nous, nous ne sommes pas islamophobes,
nous ne sommes pas racistes, nous ne
sommes pas haineux. En réalité, nous ne
faisons que répondre à la haine de la
France qui provient d'un certain nombre
de minorités. D'ailleurs, qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire le mot walisme
que tout le monde utilise ? Le mot
walkisme vient du verbe anglais.
to wake
qui veut dire se réveiller.
Donc tu as tout un tas de minorités qui
se réveillent pour proclamer que elle
ces minorités avec leur identité
minoritaire peuvent être chez elle en
France. Et pour qu'elle soit chez elle
en France, il faut qu'elle écrase
l'identité majoritaire.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Ces
fameuses minorités,
elles se sont elles se sont fait
ennuyer, emmerder pendant des années.
Qui a dit ça ? Et nous nous on l'a
constaté.
Mais non mais ça c'est ça c'est des
pareils ça. C'est c'est c'est ce que
c'est ce que la propagande avec tout le
respect que je te dois hein c'est la
c'est ce que la bois la propagande
Jan laisse-moi terminer.
Ouais vas-y.
Elles sont mon pote il s'est fait
emmerder.
Rachide Rachid machin nana ton père nain
Rachide il s'est fait emmerder. Donc ça
fait des minorités, les minorités
d'ultra gauche, les cheveux bleus,
LGBTQ, ils sont fait emmerder avec la
grappe de raisin d'insulte qui va avec
avec des Français Franchouillard
de la Campagne qui disaient "Oh la
machin, je te passe les détails de tu
connais la grappe d'insulte qui va
avec."
Bon, ces fameuses minorités que tu
décris,
elles ont fait un repli stratégique.
Elles ont elles se sont positionnées,
elles ont adapté leur discours pour être
aussi reconquête mais reconquête de leur
intégrité intellectuelle si on crée
toujours les démons des autres. Non, en
fait je comprends ce que ton point de
vue, je comprends ton point de vue, mais
l'idée c'est que
un point de vue, c'est une analyse.
Oui. Non, mais un point de vue, c'est
une analyse. Ce que je veux dire, c'est
que euh
en France,
c'est toujours le point de vue français
qui l'emportera.
C'est que en quand tu es dans un pays
qui a une identité nationale, le point
de vue de référence, c'est l'identité
nationale.
Tu peux pas décentrer
le l'identité nationale, le point de vue
national et dire en gros bah notre pays
il a pas d'identité nationale, c'est un
hall de gare et finalement toutes les
identités s' valent. Toutes les
identités peuvent faire ce qu'elles
veulent, dire ce qu'elles veulent,
s'imposer comme elles veulent. Je te
prends un exemple parce que c'est en
fait la pour bien comprendre ce que la
France subit,
il est important de symétriser une
situation sans doute fictive mais qui a
des vertus pédagogiques indéniables.
Imagine qu'au Maroc, tu parles de ton
ami marocain, imagine qu'au Maroc, tu es
euh une population de plusieurs millions
d'Africains chrétiens
qui vivent au Maroc
et qui
toutes les semaines ont une
revendication identitaire auprès des
pouvoirs marocains et du peuple
marocain. Ils veulent des débits
d'alcool partout,
ils veulent construire des églises
partout, ils veulent que leurs gamins
puisse bouffer du port à la dans les
cantines scolaires des écoles publiques
marocaines.
Et imagine que lorsque les marocains
vous disent "Vous avez pas le droit de
faire ça, cette c'est que cette
communauté africaine leur disent "Mais
fermez vos gueules en fait. Vous il y a
eu la traite araboom-musulmane, vous
nous devez quelque chose, vous avez pas
honte ? Donc aujourd'hui, on a le droit
de faire ce qu'on veut. Comment à ton
avis réagiraient les Marocains à ce
moment-là ?
Est-ce que tu crois qu'on dirait "Ah
oui, les pauvres effectivement, ils ont
peut-être souffert de discrimination et
cetera." Donc, donnons-leur ce qu'ils
veulent.
Aujourd'hui, je vais te dire,
il n'y a pas un peuple au monde et je le
dis de manière à la fois grave et
solennelle devant tes téléspectateurs.
Il y a pas un peuple au monde qui
accepterait, ne serait-ce que 1 % de ce
qu'inflige certaines immigrations au
peuple français.
Je pense que si, imagine pour filer
l'exemple de tout à l'heure que dans
cette communauté d'Africains chrétiens
de plusieurs millions qui vivent au
Maroc, il y avait quelques dingues qui
se mettaient à faire des attentats, à
égorger des imames dans des mosquées
comme le prêtre euh
à Saint-Étienne du Rouvret ou qui euh je
sais pas rafale dans une salle de
concert à Marrakech.
Comment tu crois que les Marocains du
Maroc réagiraient vis-à-vis de cette
communauté ? Et ben moi, je te file mon
billet que dans l'heure, il y aurait un
gigantesque
contre cette communauté qui serait
chassé Manu military du Maroc par
million.
Et tous les gauchistes, enfin pardon,
tous les gens de gauche qui sont en
France auraient beau jeu à ce moment-là
dire mais c'est normal, ils ont été
agressés. Alors moi, j'ai envie de poser
une question.
Tu ?
J'ai envie de poser une question. Bah,
il y a qu'à les écouter sur tous les
mouvements identitaires et
souverainistes de tous les peuples de la
terre. La gauche a toujours été du côté
de l'émancipation des peuples, de leurs
droits à disposer d'eux-mêmes, de leur
protection de de l'identité et cetera.
Moi, j'ai envie de poser aujourd'hui une
question
à aux gens de gauche en France.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi considérer
comme criminel
des réactions en France que vous
considérez comme normal voire héroïque
lorsque ces réactions émanent d'autres
peuples de la terre ?
Pourquoi la France, le peuple français
serait le seul peuple au monde qui
n'aurait pas le droit de défendre son
droit à être ce qu'il est chez lui ?
C'est quand même extraordinaire.
Faut-il rappeler à la gauche française
que l'assimilation est un concept de
gauche à la base
la gauche considérait qu'assimilé à
l'immigré, c'était le plus beau cadeau
que la France puisse faire à l'immigré
de lui dire deviens comme nous.
L'assimilation
de la gauche, c'était devient ce que
nous sommes. Ensuite, la gauche dans les
années 80, elle a dit "Non, non, restez
ce que vous êtes." C'est ce qu'on
appelle l'intégration. Il y a une
différence entre l'intégration et
l'assimilation. L'assimilation
emporte un volet identitaire et culturel
majoritaire. L'intégration est un
concept économique. C'est tu peux rester
ce que tu es, mais si tu travailles, que
tu payes tes impôts, que tu respectes
nos lois, en gros tu es un citoyen comme
les autres. Moi, pour moi, c'est pas
assez.
Respecter les lois, travailler, payer
ses impôts, c'est sans doute une
condition nécessaire mais ça ne saurait
nullement être une condition suffisante.
Bon
qui se fasse baptiser.
Non mais bah les juifs se sont pas fait
baptiser. Qui oserait dire que Léon
Bloom, Pierre Mendz France, tous les
grands noms que le la le le la
communauté juive a donné à la France à
travers les siècles, qui oserait dire
c'était pas des Français ?
George Mandel, tu sais que George Mandel
était juif, c'est un des plus grands
résistants.
On est une société judéo-chrétienne.
Oui, c'est vrai. C'est vrai. Et donc
pourquoi ? Parce que encore une fois au
début du 19e siècle, tu te rappelles de
cette phrase de Claire Montonner, Kerry
Xemour à juste titre à exumé
Claire Montonner qui dit donc du temps
de de Napoléon 1er, de l'empereur
Napoléon 1, il dit aux juifs, il dit des
juifs, pardon, tout en tant qu'individu
et citoyen, rien en tant que peuple.
Donc en gros, il convoque Napoléon le
Sanrine. C'est la vieille instance juive
des des sages
et des rabins de la communauté juive. Et
il leur dit "Vous vous délestez de tout
ce qui dans votre religion vient
percuter le code civil.
Et une fois que vous aurez considéré
votre religion comme une verticalité
uniquement et non plus comme une
horizontalité, c'est-à-dire qui qui gère
le droit de l'héritage, le droit des
femmes, le droit du divorce et cetera,
vous serez traité comme des citoyens
comme les autres. Je constate qu'à la
fin du 19e siècle, la République a eu la
main extrêmement lourde contre l'Église
catholique. On l'a oublié, mais on parle
souvent de la loi de 1905. Mais
qu'est-ce qui a précédé la loi de 1905 ?
Il y a eu une véritable guerre armée
entre la République et l'Église
catholique. Il y a eu des milliers
de jésuites, de moines, de prêtres qui
ont été forcés à l'exil
dizaines et des dizaines d'églises
fermées et détruites. L'Église
catholique a été mise au pas à la fin du
19e siècle et de manière extrêmement
brutale. Donc comment se fait-il ? Moi,
je pose la question aujourd'hui en 2025.
Comment se fait-il que les grands
prêtres, j'allais dire les oulemas de la
République française qui vous un culte à
Robespierre, à Denton, à la manière dont
la République a maté le judaïsme, à la
manière dont la République a maté
l'Église catholique, comment se fait-il
que ces gens-là fassent preuve d'une
telle mièvrerie, d'une telle molesse,
pour ne pas dire d'une telle coardise
vis-à-vis de l'islam de France ?
Qu'attend-t-on pour exiger de l'islam et
pour imposer à l'islam ce que la
République a su très bien faire pour les
deux autres religions monothéistes ? Il
est là le problème. C'est comme la
République n'exige rien
comme la République n'exige rien de
l'islam. Non seulement l'islam reste
l'islam, mais il se frérise, il se
salafise
sans que la République ne réagisse. Donc
revenons, revenons aux préconisation.
Donc
toi, tu es partisan de la remigration.
La remigration, je parlais tout à
l'heure des cercles concentriques.
Premièrement, tout ce qui est tous les
immigrés clandestin qui sont rentrés
clandestinement et qui se maintiennent
clandestinement en France, ils n'ont
rien à faire en France. Ça c'est le
premier le premier cercle. Le deuxème
cercle et ça on en parle beaucoup moins,
c'est les immigrés légaux.
Question internet. Comment le parti
reconquête définit-il concrètement une
politique d'immigration réussie entre
guillemets et quels indicateurs
mesurables entre parenthèses économiqu
sociau et sécuritaire ? Fermez la
parenthèse. Utilisez-vous pour évaluer
son efficacité dans le temps ?
Très simple. Euh aujourd'hui
encore une fois dans un dans dans
est-ce que est-ce que mon pote Mouloude
il faut qu'il s'appelle Jean-Pierre ?
C'est ce que j'allais te dire. Non pas
forcément. Pas forcément. En fait,
l'idée est très simple
et je pose la je te pose la question je
pose la question pour faire réfléchir
tes téléspectateurs
et téléspectatrices
et non mais moi téléspectateur j'aime
pas les selles et ceux et tout ça c'est
pas mon truc en français le masculin
l'emporte donc voilà ça comprend tout le
monde.
Pourquoi lorsque Cassus Clay se
convertit à l'islam il décide de
s'appeler Mohamed Ali ?
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ne rest ne rest ne
reste-t-il pas Cassus Cla ? Il prend
prénom il prend un prénom du prophète.
Pourquoi ? Bah pour faire euh
parce qu'il sait très bien. Alors
évidemment, j'ai entendu des gens dire
"Ah oui, mais parce que c'était pour
c'était parce que il voulait rejeter son
nom d'esclave noir qui était cassus clé
et il embrasse." Mais je tiens à
rappeler aux gens qui disent ça que la
traite arabo-musulmane a été une traite
bien plus meurtrière et bien plus
ancienne que la traite négrière
occidentale. Donc
troquer le le une identité occidentale
soit-disant esclavagiste pour identité
araboom-musulmane, elle aussi
esclavagiste, fallait y penser. Bon,
donc c'est pas ça la la raison. La
raison c'est parce que quand il se
convertit à l'islam évidemment que c'est
plus pratique et qu'il sera plus accepté
s'il s'appelle Mohamed en islam que s'il
s'appelle Cassus.
Donc l'idée c'est quoi ? c'est que plus
quand tu veux t'assimiler pleinement et
être considéré pleinement comme un
français sans jamais subir la moindre
bizarrerie ou la moindre discrimination,
bah effectivement, il te faut ressembler
jusqu'au bout des ongles tant tout ce
qui est possible de faire et donc
effectivement d'embrasser une identité.
Je parlais tout à l'heure de la carte
d'identité, une identité française, une
identité dans ton mode de vie, mais une
identité aussi dans ton dans ton
identité de de de prénom et cetera.
Et donc, il faut qu'il mange du ralouf,
Jean-Pierre ou pas ?
Non, mais par exemple, je vais te dire
un truc. On nous dit le voile islamique,
il est pas obligatoire.
Tu peux être une française voilée. Oui,
effectivement. Mais si tu portes le
voile islamique de grâce n'est pas
l'outre cuidance de venir nous dire ben
on regarde bizarrement dans la rue. Bah
oui. Comment regarderait-on dans la
casba algérienne
ou dans la médina marocaine un type qui
serait habillé en croisé ou même une
nana qui serait habillée de manière
outrancièrement dévêtue. On on la à tout
le moins, on la regarderait de manière
bizarre. Bon donc pourquoi ? Parce
qu'une identité nationale ne se réduit
pas à des lois.
Une identité nationale, si tu te balades
avec un uniforme de croisé dans la case,
il y a aucune loi algérienne qui dit que
c'est interdit.
Est-ce que ça t'évite pour autant de te
faire casser la figure par la population
de la case ? C'est pas si sûr. Si
tu habillé comme GF le ordi avec une
massu avec des pointes et tu fais mon
joie un saramin.
Est-ce que c'est interdit par la loi
algérienne ?
Ouais, il faut éviter de faire ça quand
même.
Voilà. Ah ben la France ça fait pas ça
fait pas exception. L'identité de la
France ne se définit pas par les lois.
Quelque chose qui peut ne pas être
interdit par la loi
n'en demeure pas moins provoquante pour
l'identité nationale du pays.
Donc le voile islamique est provocateur.
On a à peu près compris ta perception.
Euh on continue. Est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres sujets ?
Juste rapidement je conclut sur la
migration. les immigrés légaux parce
qu'on a dans l'immigration légale, on a
tendance à dire le mec, il a une carte
de séjour donc en fait il a une un
espèce de privilège à ne jamais être
viré. Excuse-moi, tu parlais tout à
l'heure de Dubaï, tu connais la sans
doute la le la la politique
d'immigration des Émirats aux Émirats si
tu cesses de travailler pendant 3 mois
que tu trouves pas de travail, qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? Même siit légal.
Hem
hem
dégage
tu pars. Donc je suis désolé mais
lorsque nous avons en France des
immigrés légaux qui soit ne foutent
rien, soit foutent le bordel soit les
deux ils n'ont aucune légitimité à se
voir reconduire leur carte de séjour et
donc et donc il partiraient tout
simplement.
Question question internet. Jean a des
origines égyptiennes.
C'est vrai, c'est ça sera difficile de
le nier.
Comment aurait-il pu vivre en France si
on avait eu une politique zéro
immigration ?
Ben parce qu'en fait ce que les gens
savent pas, c'est que moi lorsque je me
suis bon, d'abord c'est ma famille parce
que moi quand je suis arrivé en France,
j'avais 8 ans. Donc vous pensez bien que
c'est pas moi qui traversait. Le le truc
c'est que ce qu'on oublie c'est que moi
je ne suis pas venu en France en violant
des frontières. Je ne suis pas venu en
France dans le cadre du regroupement
familial. Je ne suis pas venu en France
pour me voir enfin ma famille en tout
cas pour se voir ouvrir un un logement
des aides sociales et cetera. La réalité
de la chose c'est que nous sommes
arrivés en France par ma mère qui était
chimiste de haut niveau et à qui la
France avait fait un pont en or pour
venir s'installer en France pour y
poursuivre ses ses recherches. Donc là
évidemment nous sommes pas, si vous
voulez dans l'immigration telle que la
France l'a connue dans les années 80.
Voilà. Donc et d'ailleurs lorsque ma
mère est arrivée en 77
en France, c'était pas pour être
naturalisé. Elle aurait pu faire
continuer ses recherches pendant 3 4 5
ans et si elle n'avait pas fait montre
d'un désir d'être française et si dans
son comportement elle n'était pas
devenue française, elle n'aurait jamais
été naturalisée.
Comment elle s'appelait maman ?
Elle s'appelait Fadia.
Fadia.
Euh moi si vous voulez quand j'arrive en
France en 78 je suis je suis naturalisé
en 90.
D'accord. Quand tu es arrivé en France,
tu t'appelais pas Jean ?
Non, je m'appelais Osame.
Ossame ?
Oui.
Et tu as changé par toi-même ou c'est
maman qui t'a fait changer de
? Non non, j'ai changé par moi-même
parce que moi en fait j'ai j'ai été
naturalisé. C'est moi qui ai demandé la
rends-toi compte. Ma mère avait fait une
demande de naturalisation en 86, mais
comme à l'époque mon père était
diplomate et qu'il ne vivait pas en
France parce qu'il était en poste à
l'étranger, l'État français a considéré
que le fait que mon père ne vive pas
avec nous comme étant
une vie familiale anormale qui a empêché
ma mère d'être naturalisée et donc par
par conséquent nous aussi puisque nous
étions mineurs, mon frère et moi à
l'époque. Donc c'est dire à quel point
c'était exigeant et il a fallu que
j'attende en 89
en 88 d'être moi-même majeur pour faire
une demande séparée en tant que majeur
et enfin d'être naturalisé en 90 soit 12
années après mon arrivée en France.
Pourquoi tu as choisi Jean ? Mais parce
qu'en fait quand je me quand mes parents
mes parents m'ont m'ont m'ont ont choisi
à l'état civil égyptien Ossam à une
époque l'Égypte nassérienne où les
conflits euh
religieux euh couvaient si tu veux et
donc il voulait choisir un prénom neutre
qui provoquerait pas de problème dans
les cours de recréation. Et c'est vrai
qu'Osame c'est un prénom qui peut être à
la fois chrétien mais majoritairement
musulman quand même en Égypte. Et
lorsque mes parents ont voulu me
baptiser, le prêtre a dit mais on peut
pas le baptiser sousam. Il n'y a aucun
saint qui s'appelle Osam. Donc il va
falloir que vous choisissiez un autre
prénom de baptême pour que nous
puissions le baptiser. Et donc mes
parents ont choisi Jean. Et donc j'ai
repris le prénom Jean parce que je me
suis dit que si mes parents m'avaient
enfanté dans un pays qui était chrétien,
ils auraient probablement choisi le
prénom qu'ils m'ont choisi pour mon
baptême qui est Jean. C'est pour ça que
je suis pas redevenu, enfin pas pas
devenu Jean, mais redevenu Jean.
Tu crois un ami imaginaire ?
Tu as un ami imaginaire,
c'est-à-dire tu pries, tuinvoques
les esprits.
Ah mais il est pas imaginaire, il est
tout à fait réel.
Oui oui, je je suis un chrétien
pratiquant.
Je crois que Jésus-Christ est le est le
fils du Dieu vivant. Je crois que
Jésus-Christ
a souffert sur Ponce Pilate et qu'il est
ressuscité le 3e jour. Euh oui, je crois
et c'est je crois une partie c'est c'est
merci de me poser cette question parce
que beaucoup de personnes même qui
m'arrêtent dans la rue ou qui me qui me
s'adressent à moi sur les réseaux
sociaux me disent "Mais d'où vous vient
cette force en fait avec tout ce que
vous vous prenez dans la figure ? D'où
vous vient cette force ? et ben la foi
déplace les montagnes et la foi
nationale en est une. Comme disait
Bernanos,
l'espérance est un risque à courir et
j'ai accepté de le courir. Et pour
puisque je suis sur Bernanos, il y a une
autre citation que j'adore dans un
journal de le journal du d'un curé de
campagne où il dit "Les nouveaux
convertis sont embarrassants
pourquoi je suis autant haï par la
gauche et par le système ? c'est que
quelque part je n'étais pas français, je
n'avais rien à voir avec la France et en
devenant français je montre que ce qu'il
cherche et sa charne à nier existe
puisque je le suis devenu.
Question internet.
Au cinéma, on ne voit que des films
américains, pas arabe. À la télé, on ne
voit que des séries américaines, pas
arabe. Dans les rues, dans les
commerces, il y a des mots en anglais,
pas arabe. Ça c'est pas vrai. Pas arabe.
Dans les entreprises, le bullshit est en
anglais. Pourquoi ne part-il jamais du
grand remplacement de la culture
française par les valeurs américaines ?
D'abord, bah moi je le regrette de c'est
un un vieux c'est un combat
d'arrièregarde le combat contre
l'Américain nation. Vous savez, dans les
années 90 euh quand on se faisait
traiter de Franchouillard, j'avais
tendance moi à leur répondre que c'était
des américans
euh parce que effectivement
il y a et c'est indéniable
un voilà une suprémisme ou une
colonisation
euh des esprits par les États-Unis. Oui,
c'est indénégiable, mais j'ai tendance à
considérer que depuis ce n'est plus le
danger prioritaire puisque les
États-Unis n'ont pas une population
américaine en France ou une armée
américaine en France. C'est passé, hein.
C'est les dernières bases américaines
ont ont évacué la France dans les années
60.
Il n'y a pas de présence réelle, il n'y
a pas d'irrédentisme américain qui vise
par une population qui serait américaine
en France à américaniser la France. Je
ne suis pas en train de dire que pour
autant ce n'est pas un danger, surtout
lorsque nous avons des dirigeants qui
sont en réalité des traîtres qui brade,
comme l'a fait Macron,
nos outils industriels, nos fleurons
industriels aux États-Unis, tout ça est
évidemment un danger. Et moi, je suis un
Golien dans l'âme et je veux que la
France, je suis un peu dans les dans les
pas du général Ais. Je ne sais pas si ça
vous dit quelque chose mais le général
d'armée aérienne Air a commis dans la
revue Défense nationale, je crois que
c'était en 66 ou 67, euh un article très
intéressant où euh il comment dirais-je
euh il théorisait l'usage de l'arme
atomique nouvellement. euh acquise par
la France en disant que l'indépendance
française était telle que cette arme
atomique pouvait être utilisée aussi
bien à l'est qu'à l'ouest.
Je ne sais pas si vous imaginez le
courage de ce gars. Bizarrement, il est
mort dans un accident d'avion un an plus
un an plus tard. Et moi, je suis de
cela. Je veux une France indépendante à
la fois de tous les blocs aujourd'hui.
Indépendante de la Chine, indépendante
des États-Unis, indépendante de la
Russie et une France qui sache faire
valoir ce qu'elle est, faire valoir ses
droits au sein de l'Union européenne
comme le font d'ailleurs d'autres pays.
Donc je n'ai pas de problème avec ça en
fait.
Pour père Noël
cette bah pourquoi le père Noël ?
Je sais pas. Est-ce que tu as
l'impression que la France est respectée
au sein de l'Union européenne ?
Elle ne l'est pas. Mais pourquoi ?
Dis-moi,
mais parce que les mais parce que ces
dirigeants ne se respectent pas
eux-mêmes. Quand vous avez Emmanuel
Macron qui vous dit que la France est un
pays qui a commis des crimes contre
l'humanité, vous imaginez ce que ce type
va aller porter comme voix à Bruxelles.
Je doute qu'il aille porté la voix de la
France à Bruxelles. Il se il s'imagine
comme un président de l'Europe et non
pas comme un président de la France.
Donc
il prépare peut-être son recyclage. Euh
vous savez juste un instant euh il y
avait Lord Lord M button qui était
l'émissaire britannique pendant très
longtemps au sein de l'Union européenne
avant que le la Grande-Bretagne ne
parte. Il avait cette phrase
extraordinaire he il disait euh avant
toute réunion plurinationale au sein des
instances européennes, on s'assurait
toujours pour qu'il y ait un haut
fonctionnaire français parce que c'était
la seule manière de garantir qu'on
entendrait parler contre la France.
Question internet,
c'est dramatique, hein.
Question internet de Tyffon Le Fripon,
c'est une question qui va te faire
réagir, je pense. Se rend-il compte que
le personnage qui incarne est
aujourd'hui complètement périmé ? point
d'interrogation. Ce n'est pas en criant
et en gesticulant comme il a l'habitude
de le faire dans toutes les apparitions
médiatiques que les Français se mettront
à apprécier monsieur. Je ne suis pas
entre guillemets, je ne suis pas
raciste. J'ai un ami arabe, je le suis
moi-même, on ne peut plus rien dire. Ils
doivent bien se marrer. Là où colchide
ferm les guillemets. Au-delà de la
véracité ou non de son discours se
rendent-il compte que lui et son parti
passent leur temps à le rendre
complètement inaudible du grand public
pour interrogation.
Bah en fait d'abord mon but c'est pas de
me faire aimer des Français. Mon but
c'est de dire la vérité aux français.
Je ne demande pas aux gens de m'aimer.
Je demande aux gens d'écouter ce que
j'ai à leur dire parce que ce que j'ai à
leur dire est grave. Donc on n'est pas
dans un exercice de narcissisme
dégoulinant qui voudrait que le seul
objectif de mon engagement en politique
ça soit de me faire aimer, de me faire
regarder, de me faire admirer. Je passé
l'âge. Bon, ça c'est la première le
premier point. Le deuxième point, c'est
que si on en soit si on en croit la
courbe de de de des du pourcentage des
Français qui adhèrent au test que nous
défendons, le moins qu'on puisse dire,
c'est qu'on n'est pas en en phase
d'invisibilisation.
Combien étaient les Français qui étaient
contre l'immigration il y a 30 ans et
combien sont les les Français qui sont
contre l'immigration aujourd'hui ?
Évidemment que c'est un travail de fond.
Je suis pas d'accord avec ça. La parole,
vous savez, je vous disais tout à
l'heure, j'étais un chrétien pratiquant.
Au début était le verbe. Au début était
le verbe. Sans le verbe, il y a rien. Le
verbe précède l'action. Bon, donc la une
prise de conscience, lui, ce monsieur,
lorsqu'il éduque son fils,
c'est le rêve qui précède l'action
peut-être. Mais c'est c'est lui quand il
quand ce monsieur élève son fils, il
commence pas par le lui donner une
fessée d'abord avant de lui expliquer
pourquoi il a tort. Il faut bien qu'il
commence par lui parler, par le
sensibiliser, par l'éduquer verbalement
et lorsque effectivement après il a
l'occasion d'agir, il le fait. Non,
c'est exactement ce qu'on fait dans un
parti politique. Le le la parole, la
voix qui porte surtout lorsqu'on a le
courage de la vérité, ce qui est notre
cas, c'est d'ailleurs notre slogan en
conquête, c'est pour réveiller les gens
de leur léthargie.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui va se passer s'il
reste somnambule ?
Ben, en fait, c'est la question est une
question qui n'a pas lieu d'être puisque
les gens ne restent alors on peut
regretter qu'il ne se réveille pas plus
vite et plus nombreux, ça je te
l'accorde, mais il se réveille. Selon
toi, s'il se réveille pas ou si le la
masse inertielle n'est pas suffisamment
importante, qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
Il va se passer ce que le système
antinational programme depuis 50 ans en
ayant branché le grand corps national
français sous sédation identitaire
profonde et continue. D'accord. Nous à
le camp national, nous vous nous nous
cessons de vouloir arracher toutes les
tuyauteries mortifères qui sont
accrochés à ce grand corps national
français. L'européisme,
l'immigrationnisme, le libre échangisme,
euh l'islamisation, le remplacement.
Et en fait, nous sommes attaqués parce
que on nous traite de charlatans, de
faux médecins et cetera. Alors que
ceux-là même qui se drapent des oripa
des des médecins qui vont guérir ne sont
en réalité que les médecins qui sont en
train de tuer la France. Et donc euh si
la France ne se réveille pas de cette
sédation identitaire profonde et
continue qui lui est infligée et nous
sommes là pour aider à la à la
réveiller, bah je crains que le
l'horizon euthanasique ne devienne une
réalité en fait. Tu as pas peur le fait
que
comme si si je suis ton raisonnement, tu
as pas peur que les Français qui ont été
mis sous cocotte minute, tu sais, les
Français du terroir euh bien chez nous
hm
à force d'avoir pris dans la tête dans
la tête que c'est des mauvais français
parce qu'ils sont racistes, parce qu'ils
veulent pas assimiler, parce qu'ils
donnent pas assez la main, parce que
machin, tu as pas peur qu'ils se fâchent
un bon gros coup et qu'ils aillent euh
taper ceux qui les ont mis sous cocotte
minute Bah, dans un dans un pays
normalement constitué, c'est pas ce que
je souhaite, hein. C'estàd pour ça que
je me suis engagé en politique. Je me
suis engagé en politique parce que je
pense que la politique est le seul moyen
de dégonfler dans les urnes ce qui peut
être sanglant dans les rues.
Tu sens une guerre civile arrivée ?
Ah, je sens une si en fait le scénario
est il y a il y a pas 36000 solutions.
Il y en a il y a deux scénarios. Soit
les choses changent par les urnes et la
colère se dégonfle parce que on aura
véritablement un pouvoir qui sera le
reflet de la des revendications des
Français et une réponse à leur malaise
identitaire profond que l'on cherche à
invisibiliser et à criminaliser parce
que en fait la question identitaire
c'est la question dont dont il ve dont
ils ne veulent pas parler les médias.
Dès que la question identitaire pointe
son nez dans le débat public, on
l'écrase avec d'autres questions.
Rappelle-toi pendant la présidentielle
de 2022, lorsqu'Eric Zemour avait
installé la question identitaire, le
grand remplacement et cetera dans le
débat, la divine surprise, ça a été la
guerre d'Ukraine qui a permis d'écraser
toute la présidentielle.
C'est pas une divine surprise quand
en matraquant pour le système. Si, parce
que ça lui a permis, ça lui a Attends,
une guerre, la guerre d'Ukraine, c'est
une guerre étrangère hein, c'est pas une
guerre française. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a matraqué autant ? Mais à ce moment-là
pour la guerre d'Ukraine alors qu'on n
pas matraqué sur d'autres guerres qui
sont à vol d'avion tout aussi proche que
la guerre d'Ukraine. Bon euh
quelle autre guerre est à vol d'avion
aussi proche de d'Ukraine ?
Bah je sais pas. Par exemple euh ce qui
se passe en Algérie, ça nous concerne un
peu plus ce qui se passe au sud de
l'Algérie, le Niger, tout le Al-Qaïda
dans la dans la corne de l'Afrique et
cetera. C'est quand même des des
territoires qui nous sont un peu plus
familiers nous français historiquement
que que l'Ukraine qui qui a beau être un
pays européen, je dis pas qu'il faut
s'en désintéresser mais la
l'instrumentalisation de cette guerre
pour écraser le débat public national et
écraser notamment la question
identitaire, ça je le dénonce
lorsqu'ensuite
c'est ton interprétation. Bah c'est moi
qui parle donc c'est ça tombe bien.
Question internet
de Gwen. Tous les métiers dit essentiels
applaudis pendant le Covid sont
largement occupés par des immigrés entre
parenthèses pourqui
et rémunérés en proportion inverse de
leur importance. Fermez la parenthèse.
Comment fait-on sans eux ?
Alors c'est une question extrêmement
intéressante et merci à Gwen de l'avoir
posé. Euh
donc c'est le la fameuse théorie des
métiers en tension.
Je disais en exerg à mon propos que euh
la l'argument qui consiste à dire qu'il
y a des métiers en France que les
Français ne veulent pas faire.
C'est un argument éculé qui n'a plus
aucune véracité parce que la preuve
c'est que on a trois fois plus de
chômeurs hors Union européenne que les
chômeurs nationaux. Donc cela cela
signifie que nous avons aussi des
étrangers qui ne veulent pas faire les
boulots que les Français ne veulent pas
faire.
Bon, ça c'est le premier point. Le
deuxième point c'est que à supposer
qu'il y ait des métiers que les Français
ne veulent pas faire, il faut
immédiatement rajouter à cette phrase le
complément à ces salaires là.
Il y a effectivement des métiers que les
Français ne veulent pas faire à ces
salaires là. Donc ça veut dire que
professeur des écoles,
c'est voilà. Exactement. Ces secteurs
d'activité n'intéressent pas les
Français parce qu'ils sont
sous-rémunérés.
Donc la question c'est est-ce que
d'ailleurs la Grande-Bretagne a
partiellement résolu ce problème ?
Est-ce que si on augmente les salaires
de manière significative dans ces
secteurs, est-ce qu'on attirera pas une
main d'œuvre française ? Regardez les
éboueurs de la ville de Paris.
jeune dans les années 80 et 90, les
éboueurs de la ville de Paris, c'était
que des sub-sahariens ou des maghré en
grande majorité et un peu de portugais
ou d'hispanique.
Depuis qu'il y a eu une revalérisation
salariale, des congés payés, un comité
d'entreprise,
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de
Français, en tout cas dans cette
population des éboueurs parisiens, elle
est beaucoup plus française de souche
qu'elle ne le fut il y a 30 ou 40 ans.
Française de française de souches, c'est
à partir de combien de générations que
tu es de souches ?
Non mais quand je dis français, français
de c'est pas une question de génération.
Quand je dis que français de souche,
c'est français de souche européenne.
Parce qu'évidemment que si tu remontes
au 19e ou au 20e ou ou même au 18e
siècle, il y a eu des mouvements
européens. Donc les français de souche
quand tu dis français de souche ou
français de souche européenne si tu
préfères
ou des blancs quoi.
Voilà, des blancs. Ouais, exactement.
Bah je vois pas pourquoi les les gens de
la France insoumises auraient le droit
je de vanter les noirs, les Arabes, d'en
parler comme si c'était une qualité
suprême voire divine. Et ça serait
subitement raciste de dire le mot blanc.
Donc moi, j'ai pas de problème avec ça.
S'ils veulent racialiser le débat, on
peut le racialiser, il y a pas de
problème. Donc oui, effectivement, tu as
des
Alors, j'adore. Je parle
Toi, tu es blanc ou tu es marron ?
Bah, ni l'un ni l'autre. Je suis un
français.
né en Égypte.
Aujourd'hui, tu as en France beaucoup de
Maghrébas ou d'Africains nés en France.
Tu saisis la la nuance ? Bon, donc euh
voilà, moi je suis quelqu'un qui s'est
assimilé à la France.
Donc je ne comprends pas comment on peut
critiquer
l'assimilation uniquement lorsqu'il
s'agit de l'assimilation à la France.
Par contre, quand c'est une assimilation
à l'Islam, on applaudit. Quand c'est une
assimilation euh au aux mœurs
africaines, au mœur maghébine, on
applaudit. Bah le peuple français euh
est suffisamment fier pour avoir lui
aussi le droit d'applaudir des gens qui
ne sont pas à l'origine euh de sa souche
mais qu'ils deviennent.
Question internet, immigration,
immigration, immigration. Une de ses
plus grandes réussites et qu'à force de
marteler ce même sujet en permanence, il
faut faire des efforts en orthographe
les enfants, il finit par nous faire
oublier qu'il est économiste de
formation et non pas sociologue ou
doctorant en religion. A-t-il conscience
qu'il a autant de légitimité à parler
publiquement de sociologie et d'islam
que de médecine et de sous à la perche ?
Pour comparaison, il me fait penser au
dolipran et autres médicaments qui n'ont
initialement jamais été validés par des
essais clinique mais aujourd'hui
sont encore amis sur des marchés sur le
marché car l'ancienneté et la
généralisation de l'usage ont démontré
leur innocuité. Leur partie ne serait-il
pas un peu le doliprâne de la politique
entre parenthèses mise plutôt sur la
généralisation de leurs idées que sur
l'inoquité intellectuelle ? Ferm la
parenthèse à la différence que eux ne
soulagent pas mais aggrave le mal de
tête.
Euh d'abord monsieur quand il a de la
fièvre, il prend certainement du
dolipran. Euh donc bon, ça c'est la
première chose. La deuxième chose c'est
que ce qui ce qui joue le Dolipran,
c'est plutôt les macronistes. Euh c'est
dorm c'est dorm dormez dorm brave gens.
C'est ça le dolipran, c'est de leur dire
"Ne vous réveillez pas, on va vous
gaveralgésique
identitaire pour surtout pas vous
réveiller de votre sommeil
psychotropique.
C'est ce que font les macronistes, c'est
ce que fait le système qui nous dirige
depuis tant d'années. Ça c'est la
première chose. La deuxième chose, c'est
que
l'immigration est un sujet qui concerne
tout le monde. Le jour où ce monsieur
aura sa fille violée par un OQTF ou sa
grand-mère plantée par un migrant
illégal, qu'est-ce qu'il fera ? il
s'interdira de parler des méfets de
l'immigration parce qu'il n'a pas un
doctorat en sociologie ou un doctorat
en sciences des populations. Non, je
pense que précisément encore une fois je
parle d'immigration parce que tout le
reste peut être résolu.
C'est ça le problème. C'est exactement
pourquoi les communistes, les
royalistes, les socialistes, les
centristes
s'étaient réunis au sein du comité du
Conseil national de la Résistance entre
40 et 44. Et il n'avait qu'une seule
obsession,
c'est de se réunir pour parler en
permanence de l'occupation nazi, des
méfets de l'occup. Alors évidemment,
c'est pas comparable hein, mais je dis
que lorsque la nation fait face à un
danger de mort, un une menace
existentielle,
tous les autres sujets deviennent
secondaires. La guerre d'Ukraine est
secondaire, le pouvoir d'achat est
secondaire, la dette abissale de la
France est secondaire, le chômage est
secondaire, la désindustrialisation est
secondaire parce que tous ces sujets par
une politique et une stratégie calibrée
peuvent être remis sur les rails et
peuvent être traités dans le temps, pas
par quoi un coup de baguette magique
mais dans le temps 2 ans, 3 ans, 5 ans,
10 ans, ça peut se réparer, ça peut
revenir. Encore une fois, on doit être
obsédé uniquement par ce qui est
définitif.
L'urgence, elle est dans ce qui est
irréversible.
Si à force d'immigration, de
remplacement, d'islamisation, la France
et ses bien parti hélas cesse d'être ce
qu'elle est, ce pays que nous avons
connu, ce que les moins de 20 ans ont
connu, et bien plus rien ne peut la
ramener
lorsque l'Empire romain d'Orient s'est
effondré en 1453
et que aujourd'hui vous avez les
Ottomans, les Turcs qui sont
propriétaires de Constantinople devenu
Istanbul.
de la cathédrale Sainte-Sophie qui est
devenue la grande mosquée d'Istanbul.
Qui peut aujourd'hui dire "Ah mais c'est
pas grave, à l'époque, au moment où de
du siège de 1453, on était plus
préoccupé par le pouvoir d'achat, par
les moyens consacrés à s'habiller, à
manger, à se loger et cetera. Qui peut
aujourd'hui venir dire "Attendez, mais
on se trompe là, nous voulons que
Constantinople soit restitué et que la
mosquée redevienne Saint-Soufie. C'est
pas possible.
Ce n'est pas possible. Donc la France si
elle disparaît et si comme le disait le
général de Gaulle, un jour mon village
deviendrait colomber les deux mosquées,
plus personne ne pourrait rétablir
Colomber les deux églises. Donc lorsque
un pays fait face à une menace mortelle
et définitive, il est parfaitement
normal que cette menace soit
obsessionnelle et qu'on cherche à la
contrecarrer. Absolument.
Question internet. Messieurs, bonsoir.
Vous parlez d'identité française à juste
titre. Mais quand reste-t-il aujourd'hui
? L'inculture concerne d'abord les entre
guillemets français de souche.
C'est vrai.
Regardez la qualité du français de la
majorité de nos concitoyens.
La connaissance de l'histoire de France,
de ses grands hommes, de ses haut lieux.
Même dans nos assiettes, la mort des
bistro remplacé par les faon bistro ça
veut dire c'est du russe he d'ailleurs
les enfants même dans nos assiettes la
mort des bistros remplacé par les fast
food américains et les kebabs on parle
de principes et de valeurs mais de quel
de mais desquels parle-t-on
l'assimilation est un principe
mimétique.
Qu'est-ce que l'immigré pourrait-il donc
mimer ? interrogation. Comment demander
à des individus de participer à un grand
rien pour interrogation ? Mais c'est
tout à fait vrai. C'est tout à fait
vrai. Lorsque encore une fois vous avez
tout un système politique de droite
comme de gauche qui pendant des années
vous a expliqué que la que la France
n'existe pas, que l'identité nationale
n'existe pas, qu'au fond la France ce
n'est qu'un morceau du globe terrestre,
ce n'est qu'un grand marché où les gens
ne sont que des agents économiques
interchangeables.
Lorsqu'on vous dit que la France non
seulement est un grand terrain vague sur
lequel n'importe qui venant de n'importe
où, se comportant n'importe comment et
partant et parlant n'importe quelle
langue peut-être français, effectivement
oui, on dénature la France à l'époque et
c'est tout à fait vrai ce que dit ce
monsieur. À l'époque moi je savais à
quoi je devais m'assimiler parce que la
France était fière d'elle-même. La
France était française et donc on
s'assimilait à une France qui était
française. Tu avais les cheveux longs,
j'avais une coupe à fro.
Non, je déconne.
Euh, j'avais les cheveux plus longs que
ça. En tout cas, l'âge, tu sais. Euh, et
donc
façon, c'est Jérôme ou un peu boys band
ou pas du tout ?
Non, j'ai une coupe mulet
euh
coupe mulet.
Et
aujourd'hui, évidemment, comme le la
boussole qui est l'identité française de
la France a été éparpillée face puzzle
par un système qui n'y croit pas voir
qui la est, effectivement, on peut pas
s'assimiler. Euh, vous savez, il y avait
un moi je les gens qui nient l'identité
nationale française, voir qui ni le
peuple de sous, je leur demande juste de
me regarder au fond. Moi, je n'étais pas
français. Je n'avais rien à voir avec la
France et je parlais pas un seul mot de
français quand je suis arrivé.
Aujourd'hui, je suis devenu quoi ?
Qu'est-ce que vous avez en face de vous
? parce que par définition, on ne
s'assimile pas à rien. Mais encore une
fois, du haut de mes 55 ans, je reflète
ce qu'était l'identité française et la
nation française à laquelle je me suis
assimilé il y a 40 ans.
Évidemment qu'aujourd'hui, vu qu'on a
balancé par-dessus bord que le nos
élites qui sont censées être les
garantes de la France, de l'identité
française et et et comment dirais-je de
l'ipséité nationale, lorsque ces élites
ont balancé par-dessus bord tout ce qui
constitue la France, bah effectivement
oui, c'est plus compliqué de s'assiler à
un pays dont les élites nous expliquent
que ce n'est pas un pays en fait qu'il
n'a pas d'identité. Question internet,
il a beaucoup de questions pour gens ce
soir. Le storytelling de son
assimilation parfaite m'agaass
l'impression que si on fait comme lui
tout ira bien
ce qui est faux.
Je non je te confirme.
Attends.
Mes parents tous les deux, tous deux
algériens nous ont assimilé
parfaitement. Ils nous ont pas enseigné
l'arabe. On ne parlait que français à la
maison. Nous ne sommes pas musulmans. On
aime la charcuterie. le Bon pinard et le
fromage 2. Hors des discriminations,
j'en ai eu plein entre autres coupé le
gris quand on jouait au rugby dans le
sud-est.
Un prof de math qui ne me comprenait pas
étant donné mes origines que j'étais si
bon en math. On m'a traité de Salbou en
primaire, ma directrice de test qui me
sort après avoir fait une présentation
en anglais que la présentation était
nickel à part à l'accent de Yasser
Arafat. Attends, je descends la ligne
parce qu'ils me font des questions longs
comme le bras.
Je reprends la phrase nickel à part
l'accent de Yasser Arafat alors que il y
a pas plus français que mon accent
British. Yeah man. Ma question est-il
possible qu'il se remette en question et
challenge ses propres schémas ? Est-il
possible d'admettre qu'effectivement en
France on a parfois des réflexes assez
bizarres dès que le prénom a des
consonances maghrébines sans avoir à
changer notre prénom ou renier ? toutes
nos racines.
Bah je pense si vous voulez que oui, je
s'il est indéniable que l'immigration
haineuse de la France que le système
antinational a promu, c'està-dire celle
qui brûle, celle qui casse, celle qui
multiplie les agressions, la
délinquence, la criminalité qu'on
présente presque comme des victimes. Je
parle par exemple d'Adama Traoré ou de
Naël, un petit ange parti trop tôt comme
disait euh de lui un footballeur
célèbre. Euh toutes ces immigrations,
c'est un mom, c'est un mom qui s'est
pris quand même une bastos.
Bah c'est un délinquant qui avait
plusieurs
Ça ça reste un mom
quand on
il était mineur à l'époque, non ? Il
était Oui mais enfin il était mineur à
bord d'un bolide qui vaut 85000 boules
euh qui nétait donc qu'il avait loué
qu'il conduisait sans permis qui
conduisait à tout mom
quand un quand un policier vous demande
de vous arrêter et de couper le moteur
un mom
quand un policier te demande de
t'arrêter et de couper le moteur il faut
que tu obtempères si tu refuses
d'obtempérer tu mets le doigt
effectivement dans un processus qui peut
être fatal
quel pays au monde dans quel pays au
monde on va expliquer quer à une
personne que c'est presque faire de la
résistance que ne pas s'arrêter quand un
flic te demande de t'arrêter. Tu crois
que un AEL il aurait survécu face à la
police algérienne ou face à la police
marocaine, face à la police tunisienne
ou face à la police égyptienne ou face à
une police africaine ? Ils auraient été
peut-être plus malins, ils auraient tiré
dans les pneus et ensuite ils l'auront
pas du tout dans la position dans
laquelle était le policier au moment où
ça s'est où le drame s'est passé. Je
peux te dire que il aurait pas attendu
que le mec essaie de redémarrer pour
tirer. Et la différence, c'est que dans
ces pays-là, le flic aurait été
applaudi. Il aurait pas été traité de
criminel comme ici.
Bon, tu as compris la question de du
monsieur ?
Oui. Euh oui, c'est vrai. Donc à force
de promouvoir des immigrations haineuses
de la France, évidemment que il y a des
effets collatéraux sur les immigrés qui
eux n'ont rien demandé à personne et qui
se contentent de vivre normalement.
J'ajoute que il est évident que lorsque
j'entends dire que si je suis une
victime de quelque chose, et bien la
société me reconnaîtra davantage. Mais
moi-même, je peux aller piocher dans ma
propre histoire des exemples de mots
qu'on m'a dit quand je suis arrivé quand
je savais pas parler très bien français,
quand je passais des heures de sport
collectif quand j'étais à l'école parce
que je ne savais pas parler français que
on ne me choisissait pas. Non mais ça
c'est parce que tu avais un physique
chétif quand tu t'es inscrit au rugby.
Bah j'étais d'abord j'étais pas inscrit
au rugby, j'étais inscrit au football et
d'ailleurs la le premier le le premier
courageux qui m'a choisi dans son équipe
et que j'ai marqué trois buts parce que
en Égypte on apprend à faire à jouer au
football avant de savoir marcher. Euh
après j'ai on se battait pour m'avoir
dans l'équipe. Bon, tu tu donc il faut
arrêter de monter en épingle euh des
expériences qui peuvent être
désagréables mais qui ne disent rien du
pays. Moi je je suis sidéré si tu veux
que nous avons aujourd'hui en France
des immigrés en très grand nombre dont
le métier est de t'expliquer que la
France est un pays raciste, que la
France est un pays haigneux, que les
Français ne sont pas accueillants, que
la France que les Français sont des pays
sont des sont un peuple qui se moque de
toi quand tu es différent et cetera.
Mais comment est-ce que des immigrés
peuvent venir par millions en France
tous les ans juste pour te dire que tu
es raciste ? Je te coupe.
Moi je leur dis envoie un mail quoi mec
c'est plus c'est plus rapide plus
économique pour Là là on a parlé des
sans papiers de ceux qui étaient sur le
territoire alors qu'ils avaient pas le
droit. Laisse-moi terminer. Laisse-moi
terminer.
Ça veut dire quoi ? Pas que
on a pas parlé que de ça.
D'accord. Oui. Bien sûr. Et ceux qui
sont français avec une carte nationale
d'identité française de première
génération, 2e génération, 3e génération
et qui selon toi ou selon leur attitude
ne sont pas intégrés, ne sont pas
assimilés.
Tu fais comment pour te réconcilier ce
beau petit monde ?
Moi, j'ai j'ai rien à faire pour me
réconcilier ce bon petit monde.
Tu fais comment pour les Je leur dis je
le je leur donne la je le je leur donne
en réponse la phrase de Kennedy. Ne
demande pas ce que ton pays peut faire
pour toi. Demande-toi ce que toi tu peux
faire pour ton pays. Faut arrêter de
jeindre, arrêter de te plaindre. On a on
a été des générations d'immigrés dans
les années 50 60 70 Portugais, des
espagnols, des chrétiens d'Orient, des
asiatiques aussi, les bot people et
cetera. Bien sûr, ça était difficile au
début. Qui quel immigré qui vient dans
un pays te dirait que c'est pas
difficile, que c'est pas compliqué,
qu'il a pas rencontré des tas de regards
bizarres, de différences et cetera. Mais
l'essentiel, il est pas là. L'essentiel,
c'est toi de te remettre en question
pour t'adapter au pays. Il faut pas il
faut arrêter avec ce cette ce poison
qu'on a inoculé dans le cerveau des gens
qui consiste à dire si le pays est
bizarre avec toi, c'est au pays de
changer. C'est pas au pays de changer.
La France ne changera pas. Et je ne veux
pas qu'elle change. Et je ne veux pas
que le peuple français change. Si tu as
un problème avec la France, ne demande
pas à la France de changer. Demande-toi
ce qu'il faut que tu fasses pour
t'adapter à la France. Ça a l'air brutal
ce que je dis, mais c'est comme ça dans
tous les pays du monde encore une fois.
Bon, la dernière question sur ce sur ce
registreel parce que j'ai encore qu'une
demi-heure avec Jean parce qu'il a une
grande conférence juste après. Euh
question : "Vous parlez d'identité
française et de valeur, mais en quoi
votre vision fondée sur l'exclusion et
la hiérarchie entre les Français
diffèrent-elle réellement de ce que la
République a toujours combattu ? On
n'est pas pour l'hérit français. Au
contraire, nous défendons l'idée d'une
France une et indivisible et d'un peuple
français un et indivisible. Euh c'est
justement lorsqu'on caresse dans le sens
du poil les différences. Lorsque par
exemple Emmanuel Macron, c'est sa
dernière lubi nous sort un haut
commissariat à la diversité. Qu'est-ce
qu'il fait ? Il surf sur les différences
et sur les fractures du pays au point de
les institutionnaliser.
Nous nous ne disons pas cela. Au
contraire,
ils sont ils se ils sont on va dire que
il s'y prend comme un manche.
Bah je ne sais Bah non, il s'y prend
comme il s'y prend comme son idéologie.
Il se prend comme un manche comme
d'habitude sur tous les sujets.
Qu'est-ce qu'il disait Trump sur Macron
? Tout ce qui touche ça se transforme en
merde.
En plomb ? Ouais. Ouais. Transforme leur
en plomb. Mais c'est mais c'est pas
faux.
Trump. Bah je parle pas de Midas.
Ouais.
Moi je te dis que inversé d'ailleurs
la pour que en fait pour que les gens
puissent s'assimiler à un pays et à une
identité encore faut-il que ce pays
mette en avant son identité, soit fier
de son identité. On on ne s'assimile pas
à rien. D'accord ? Si l'assimilation a
été rendue possible il y a 50 ans, c'est
pour deux raisons. Un, parce que les
immigrés étaient beaucoup moins
nombreux. On assimile des individus, on
assimile pas des peuples entiers. Et
deux, parce que la France était fière de
ce qu'elle était et que tout le monde
savait très bien ce qu'était la France.
Aujourd'hui, si tu veux, quand on dit
quand quand à plusieurs repris sur des
plateaux de télévision, face même à des
élus et qui me disent "Mais mais enfin
monsieur, c'est quoi la France pour vous
Un pays vient à se demander ce qu'il
est, un pays qui vient à se demander ce
qu'est son identité, c'est qu'il n'a
plus d'entité et et il n'est plus ce
qu'il est d'une certaine façon. Parce
qu'à la vérité, tuentendras jamais au
Maroc ou en Égypte ou en Tunisie
quelqu'un qui te dira "C'est quoi le
Maroc ? C'est quoi l'Égypte ?" Toi qui a
vécu en Égypte, tu as déjà entendu un
Égyptien vécu. J'ai passé beaucoup de
temps là.
D'accord. Tu as déjà entendu un Égyptien
te dire "C'est quoi l'identité
égyptienne ?"
Bah, ça dépend dans le nord ou dans le
sud.
Les deux. Aucun te c'est quoi l'identité
égyptienne. C'est c'est des composants.
Enfin, l'identité égyptienne, c'est pas
un truc monolithique. L'identité
égyptienne, c'est un chapeau d'arabité,
d'islam d'islamité et cetera.
Euh plutôt pharaonique hein, parce que
dans le sud
dépend ça dépend où, mais l'Égypte est
un pays arabe, c'est devenu un pays
arabe, c'est devenu un pays musulman.
Euh voilà euh les seuls qui cultivent
quelque part euh une idée de l'Égypte
telle qu'elle était avant, c'est les
copes de part justement l'église euh euh
la langue et cetera, mais c'est
epsilonesque dans dans dans l'identité
nationale de l'Égypte actuelle qui est
une identité arabo-musulmane.
Bon
et personne ne n'ira interroger cette
identité. Donc le simple fait de dire
c'est quoi la France,
il est là le problème.
Question internet. L'invité est-il
encore pour la sortie de l'Union
européenne, de l'euro et de l'OTAN pour
interrogation ? Si oui, pourquoi
reste-t-il chez Reconquête pour
interrogation ? Si non, pourquoi avoir
changé d'avis ?
Non, c'est pas une question de changer
d'avis. Moi je pense et d'ailleurs
j'avais soutenu, comme je te l'ai dit,
une thèse de doctorat pour pour
expliquer et pour analyser que l'idée
d'une de passage à une Union européenne
en l'absence d'union politique
préalable, cette idée de se de retrouver
avec une monnaie unique et une politique
budgétaire décentralisée n'était pas une
bonne idée, tant s'en faut. Donc euh
j'étais tout j'ai toujours été dans la
lignée, c'est d'ailleurs mes premiers
amours et mes premiers combats
politiques, c'était dans la sphère
souverainiste à une époque où les
questions identitaires ne se posaient
pas avec autant d'acuité euh qu'elle se
pose aujourd'hui. L'idée, si tu veux,
c'est que aujourd'hui,
aucun candidat ne sera élu sur l'idée
d'une sortie de l'Union européenne ou
une sortie de la zone euro. Parce que
les Français gardent, et c'est bien
normal, un effet de mémoire par rapport
au changement monétaire entre le franc
et l'euro. Alors même que c'était un
changement monétaire qui avait été
organisé, coordonné, planifié, c'est
quand même resté un traumatisme. Alors à
Forceuri, un changement monétaire
unilatéral que proposerait un un
candidat français en disant si vous
votez pour moi, je sors de l'ob. OK, on
prend très vite. Un candidat propose ça,
il arrive miracle, il est en tête des
sondages au premier tour et son projet
c'est de sortir de la zone euro.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Fuite des
capitaux. Les gens s'inquiètent.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? C'est quoi
les modalités de passage de l'euro au
franc de nouveau ?
Attaque attaque de la dette.
Attaque de la dette. Fuite de capitaux.
OK. Alors, on me dit "Mais non, mais ça
on peut l'éviter en mettant en place un
contrôle d'échange. Mais comment ça, tu
es pas au pouvoir encore ? Tu pourras
rien mettre du tout." Et ceux qui sont
au pouvoir comme ils sont contre ce que
tu proposes, au contraire, leur intérêt
c'est de laisser le bordel s'installer
et les le désordre et cetera s'installer
pour dire aux électeurs voyez ces
gens-là sont pas au pouvoir, c'est déjà
la merde. Donc votez pas pour eux. Donc
ça peut pas arriver. Donc à reconquête,
l'idée est simple. Tu fais
le problème non c'est pas ça. Le
problème n'est pas en soit l'Union
européenne ou l'euro. C'est que nous
avons des élites qui ne défendent pas à
l'intérieur de la zone euro et à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne les
intérêts français. Donc nous ce qu'on
propose c'est très pragmatique. Nous
allons être élus avec une France qui est
dans l'Union européenne et qui est dans
la zone euro et nous allons totalement
changer le logiciel en allant exiger des
instances européennes
de respecter le mandat qui a été celui
qui nous a été donné par le peuple
français, c'est-à-dire sur
l'immigration, sur la dette et cetera et
cetera. de deux choses l'une où l'Union
européenne dit "Mais attendez, non, on
va pas faire ça." Et nous on va dire
"Oui, si on va le faire parce que le
peuple français dont nous nous tenons le
suffrage et bien pour nous, il est plus
important que quelques fonctionnaires
payer 20000 € par mois et qui n'ont de
compte à rendre à personne."
Il est plus important ou si tu respectes
pas ta parole, ils vont venir te
tabasser la gueule à coup de fourche ?
Bah, il est plus si je respecte pas ma
parole, comment ? Ben, on va dire "Bah,
écoutez, moi le peuple français veut
qu'on modifie les traités."
Ah oui, mais nous on veut pas qu'on
modifie les traités. D'accord. Donc ça
veut dire qu'on vous êtes prêt à une
explosion de de l'Union européenne en
fait et à une explosion de l'euro qui va
vous impacter aussi. Ah non non. Ben on
va se mettre autour de la table. J'ai on
a aussi pensé au représaill parce que
regarde ce qui s'est passé en Grèce. La
Banque centrale européenne parce que la
Grande-Bretagne elle n'était pas dans
l'ozono. Donc le la représaille
monétaire n'était pas possible. Nous la
représaille monétaire est possible.
C'estàd qu'ils peuvent la banque
centrale européenne peut fermer les
robinets et nous couper les liquidités.
Sauf que avec tout le respect que je
dois au peuple grec, le la France n'est
pas la Grèce. La France c'est le deè la
France c'est le deuxème contributeur au
budget européen. On on donne à peu près
10 milliards nets chaque année à l'Union
européenne. Donc tu veux nous emmerder
sur la monnaie, on t'emmerdera sur le
budget si tu coupes 10 milliards du jour
au lendemain.
Tu veux tu veux une autre petite idée ?
Si tu as des problèmes, tu dis écoute,
fais pas de ton malin est-ce qu'on va
couper l'électricité aux Allemands.
Oui, mais si tu veux, toi et moi, on a
les idées de de Français qui ont en
ligne de mire non seulement l'intérêt
français, mais la capacité de la France
à se défendre avec les atouts qu'elle a.
C'est pas du tout le logiciel qui nous
dirige. Le logiciel qui nous dirige ne
pense pas en terme de français,
d'Allemand, de belge et cetera. Le le
logiciel qui nous dirige pense en terme
d'un salmigondi européen. Euh ben Dogo
le disait, on peut pas faire une
omelette avec des œufs durs. Ben Macron,
il a réussi cette prouesse. Oh,
tu es horrible. Tu es horrible.
Voilà. Hor,
je vais te poser une question et
d'ailleurs, je suis je suis pas content
de la tournure de la question et je suis
fâché mais je vais quand même la poser
quand même parce que c'est pas bien mais
je vais quand même la poser et c'est on
avait dit qu'on changeait de sujet mais
je vais quand même la poser quand même.
Regarde pas ta montre avant que je me
fâche.
Pensez-vous qu'une majorité des gens qui
votent ern et de l'extrême droite vous
assimile comme un français point
d'interrogation.
Ne pensez-vous pas que dans ces français
de souche, beaucoup pensent que monsieur
Jean Messia, vous devez quand même
partir de France malgré l'effort que
vous mettez dans votre syndrome du
Larbin pour interrogation.
Non, le syndrome du Larbin, c'est le
c'est ce monsieur qui parle. Euh moi, je
milite dans le camp national depuis
maintenant 11 ans, comme je le rappelais
tout à l'heure, depuis fin 2014. Donc ça
fait maintenant presque 11 ans que je
suis dans le camp national. Je n'ai
jamais eu aucun militant et aucun
adhérent qui m'a renvoyé à mes origines,
qui me renvoie aujourd'hui à mes
origines. Et j'invite ce monsieur à
aller voir les réponses systématiques
euh des gens qui sont dans son camp à
mes postes qui me traite d'arabe de
service, qui me traite de bougou de
service, qui me dit que je suis un
larbin comme ce monsieur. C'est pas des
à moins que ce monsieur se définisse
comme étant quelqu'un d'extrême droite.
il se il se définit bien comme quelqu'un
d'antie extrême droite et pourtant c'est
lui qui utilise le terme de l'arbin.
Donc il devrait se poser des questions
ce monsieur. C'est ce monsieur qui est
raciste.
C'est pour ça je sais pas qu'on la fin
de la la fin de la phrase c'était pas
sympa. Euh bon tu es quand même
économiste. Nous on a un principe un peu
comme avec les reporters, les
économistes ou les gé géopolitologues.
On va prendre le spectre économiste.
Donc tu es économiste, tu comprends
l'économie. Oui, en principe,
oui, la majeure partie des économistes
qu'on a reçu, il panaî rien à
l'économie.
C'est quoi ? Quelles ont été tes
dispositions que tu as pris pour toi ?
Parce que tu vois bien que l'économie va
se vautrer dans pas très longtemps ou
l'euro va se vautrer dans pas très
longtemps. Tu l'as senti en tant
qu'économiste, tu sais que l'euro est
une monnaie fantôme, le dollar est une
monnaie fantôme
basé basé sur des gros flingues.
Ouais, les gros flingues.
Tu as pris des dispositions pour toi
pour sécuriser un peu ton cul, tes
fesses, ta famille quand la monnaie va
se casser la gueule ? Bah, je l'aurais
acheté à l'appartement déjà, donc c'est
pas mal. C'est une belle connerie.
C'est la pierre. Ouais. Non mais le sang
coule pas encore dans les rues. Mais
mais la pierre un jour il y a un grand
banquier international qui nous connaît
très très bien depuis des années, il m'a
dit "Fais attention parce que c'était en
2017. Si ton scénario de guerre avec les
Russes se matérialise, ça risque d'être
compliqué pour les États et le premier
truc qu'ils vont taxer, c'est
l'immobilier et l'épargne. Donc reste
liquide, il faut que tu puisses bouger.
Hop ! En en 24 heures.
Bah liquide c'est Oui, c'est compliqué.
Sauf que si tu me dis que l'euro c'est
une monnaie de singe,
tu as acheté Tu as acheté Ouais, c'est
une monnaie de singe. Euh
le dollar c'est une monnaie de singe. Il
parle de quelle liquidité en fait ?
On dira pas que c'est une monnaie de
singe. On dira que c'est une monnaie de
Karen.
D'accord. Il parle de quelle liquidité
en fait ? Parce que ça cette cette ces
liquidités là s'effondreront aussi.
Non mais autre chose diversifier. L'or,
moi je moi je alors de par mes origines,
je l'or, ça a toujours été la valeur
refuge de toute façon de manière
générale. Et quand on voit les
performances de l'or sur les deux
dernières années, ça vient dire deux
choses. Ça vient de dire que c'est la
valeur refuge par excellence et surtout
ça vient aussi dire que il y a de plus
en plus d'acteurs à la fois individuels
mais de plus en plus institutionnel et
étatique qui achètent des grosses
quantités d'or parce que ils anticipent
probablement un effondrement du système
international fondé sur le roi dollar.
Tu suis les cours des des commodities en
ce moment ou pas du tout ?
Je je je les suivis.
Tu suis l'argent en ce moment ? L'argent
physique ? l'argent euh Ah oui oui,
l'argent a beaucoup progressé aussi
hein. L'argent a énormément progressé.
Bon le problème c'est que pour ceux qui
ont euh des quantités de liquides de
dépargne liquide importante, l'argent
physique c'est compliqué hein. Il va
falloir des containers entiers euh pour
les contenir. L'avantage de l'or, c'est
que quand tu as je sais pas le le lingot
d'or qui euh qui est à 120000 ou 100000
€0000
120000 126000 je crois de de mémoire
kilo d'argent là physique tu dois
pouvoir le toucher à 3000 balles là.
Voilà, c'est ça. Alors, évidemment, tout
dépend de ton de ton épargne en fait,
mais je dirais que pour les ceux qui
veulent vraiment mettre à l'abri des
grosses sommes, l'argent constitue
ensuite un il a des inconvénients en
terme de stockage et cetera parce qu'en
fait dans la perspective de ce que tu me
disais, genre une guerre éclair russe et
cetera, al je comprends que l'immobilier
va être taxé, peut même être détruit
pendant la guerre et cetera mais je veux
dire tout autant que l'or physique parce
qu'aujourd'hui le par définition l'or tu
peux pas l'acheter au marché noir. quand
tu vas acheter de l'or chez un changeur,
bah il te prend ton identité, ta carte
et cetera. Tout est tracé en fait et
quand tu revends, il y a une taxe à la
revente par rapport à la plus-value.
Enfin, tout ça est institutionnalisé et
tracé depuis longtemps, verrouillé
depuis longtemps. C'est pas alors à
moins que tu es tu es hérité, je sais
pas, de plusieurs lingots d'une vieille
grand-mère à cariatâtre dont tu as
découvert le mago qu'elle n'a jamais
voulu te laisser dans l'un de ses des
murs de son appart. Si tu veux
aujourd'hui convertir des liquidités en
or, euh tu tu peux pas le faire euh euh
de manière euh parallèle au circuit
officiel. Or, le circuit officiel
t'identifie, te trace et cetera. Donc
bon,
là, tu sens euh quoi pour l'économie
française ? Est-ce que tu sens que
Macron a été et son principal bras droit
Bruno Leber ? Les gens solaires, ces
leaders charismatiques qui ont une
compréhension perforante de l'histoire.
Perforante. Ouais.
Ouais. Il laisse des trous partout.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Et tu penses qu'on est vraiment dans la
merde là ou bien ?
Je pense que nous sommes dans une très
mauvaise posture euh dans une mauvaise
posture économique pour deux raisons.
C'est que je ne sais pas si tu as vu,
mais il est il est quand même assez
sibilin et assez intéressant de
constater qu'Emmanuel Macron est en
train de suivre dans le domaine agricole
parce que le sujet d'actualité en ce
moment de révolte et cetera, c'est la
révolte des agriculteurs et une révolte
saine et tout à fait juste vis-à-vis du
Mercossure.
Emmanuel Macron est en train d'être
comment dire le liquidateur terminal
de l'agriculture comme il le fut dans
son premier mandat pour l'industrie.
C'est-à-dire que dans les années 80 et
la forfaiture ça. Ah pour moi, pour moi,
tous ceux qui ont gouverné la France
depuis une quarantaine d'années et donc
évidemment singulièrement Emmanuel
Macron devrait être jugé pour autres
trahison. Parce que en fait moi ce qui
m'échappe c'est qu'on te dit le
cafarnaum identitaire, sécuritaire,
économique, industriel, agricole dans
lequel nous vivons, c'est un phénomène
météorologique. En fait, c'est la faute
à personne. C'est un jour tu te lèves
touffes tes fenêtres, il pleut.
La veille, il faisait beau, c'était la
France tel que nous l'avons connu,
industrialisé, riche, son budget était
équilibré, le Concorde, les centrales
nucléaires, la bombe à neutron, le siège
à l'ONU, tout ça.
Et du jour au lendemain, donc il
faisaiit il faisait beau la veille et du
jour au lendemain, il pleut. C'est la
faute à personne. Il y a pas de
responsabilité. Mais c'est pas c'est pas
vrai. Les Français,
tu peux tu penses que ça va se terminer
? Les Français doivent savoir que ce
n'est pas vrai que ceux qu'ils vivent
aujourd'hui sur tous les plans en terme
de paupérisation, en terme de perte
d'identité, en terme d'insécurité,
c'est le résultat de politique
fanatiquement poursuivie depuis 40 ans.
Est-ce que tu penses que quand les
Français vont réellement s'en rendre
compte plus que à l'heure actuelle,
c'est-à-dire encore plus rien dans les
frigos, plus de boulot, de la violence
partout et puis peut-être des bombes
russes, est-ce que tu penses pas qu'ils
vont installer des hachoirs avion de
place de la Concorde et qu'ils vont
faire des grandes files avec les gars
qui ont été traîres à la patrie ?
Bah en tout cas, si l'on se réfère à
l'histoire de France, le peuple français
n n'a jamais été tendre avec ses
dirigeants et encore moins lorsque ses
dirigeants les ont trahis. Je rappelle
quand même que Louis X a été décapité
pour moins que ça. He
Est-ce que tu penses qu'il nous
trahissent ou ils se rendent pas compte
?
Ah, ils nous trahissent.
Non, mais d'accord, ils nous trahissent.
Mais est-ce qu'ils s'en rendent compte ?
Oui ou non ?
Bah s'il s'en s'ils s'en rendent pas
compte, c'est quoi l'argument ? C'est
des dingues. Ils ne voi pas ce qu'ils
font. Ils ne voi pas le résultat de ce
qu'ils font. Enfin, je sais pas un
président
des dingues ou des drogués.
Ah mais un un
drogué au pouvoir.
Un un président de la République,
excuse-moi, mais il a des outils de
souveraineté à sa disposition. Il a le
ministère de l'intérieur, il a les notes
blanches du DRG, il connaît la situation
du pays, il connaît la même pas
seulement le malaise des Français, mais
il sait même comment comment ce malaise
est formulé. Donc si s'il y a bien un
qui connaît l'État du pays, qui est
capable de t'en parler de manière
extrêmement fine, c'est le président de
la République vers qui monte tous les
capteurs euh que sont ceux de l'État sur
le territoire national. Donc je je
n'imagine pas si tu veux que nos
dirigeants euh à ce point ignorent les
souffrances des Français euh qu'ils en
viennent à se dire "Bah non, continuez,
tout va bien madame la Marquise. C'est
pas possible. S'ils disent tout va bien
madame la marquise", ils peuvent le dire
mais on ne peut pas nous faire croire
qu'ils ignorent qu'en disant cela ils
mentent.
Ils ont pas vu venir les gilets jaunes.
Ça les a vachement surpris.
Pens que tu penses que leurs sondes
elles sont opérationnelles lorsquand
des agriculteurs qui suicident tous les
jours ?
Non, ce que je dis c'est que ils
connaissent ils connaissent le malaise
profond des Français. Je ne suis pas en
train de dire qu'ils connaissent à
l'avance comment ce malaise va
s'exprimer. Ça c'est une autre chose.
Les gilets jaunes, ça n'a été que
comment dire une projection
de lave
euh comment dirais-je
lave qui qui qui exprime ce malaise.
Mais effectivement, ils avaient pas vu
venir les l'éruption de ce volcan de
cette manière-là. Mais toi, tu es en
train de me dire peut-être qu'ils
ignorent qu'il y a un volcan. Moi, je te
dis qu'il ils n'ignorent pas qu'il y a
un volcan. Ils font tout pour pas qu'il
y ait d'éruption. D'ailleurs, quand il y
a une éruption tout de suite, alors
c'est très drôle, c'est le
l'hélicoptère, vous savez, tu sais le
euh il lâche de l'eau comme les
hélicoptères de la sécurité civile, les
Canadaires qui lâchent de la flotte sur
un incendie naissant. Alors, sauf que
dans dans le cas d'une crise sociale
comme celle qui a été crisé jaunes, on
appelle ça la monnaie hélicoptère.
visualisage surtout la monnaie flic
parce que quand tu vois 300 tracteurs
15000 flics c'est qu'il commence à avoir
un petit peu peur il y a ça et puis pour
éteindre définitivement l'incendie il a
quand même bazardé entre 10 et 15
milliards d'euros euh voilà de primes
diverses et variées et cetera, ce qui a
fait que les gens sont rentrés chez eux.
Donc il y a un volcan identitaire.
le pouvoir s'acharne à faire en sorte de
le maintenir sous contrôle et à faire en
sorte que euh que la lave ne sorte pas
parce qu'il sait très bien que si la
lave explose, elle elle est toujours
violente en France et elle peut tout
emporter sur son passage. Donc c'est
pour ça qu'il est obsédé par ça. Mais
nul ne peut prévoir, nul ne peut
garantir que cette lave n'explose
jamais.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Euh, la messe n'est pas dite d'Éric
Zemour.
Euh, je n'ai pas dit des mon derniers
mots d'Éric Zemour.
Tu cends mais
et le suicide français,
je vais te refaire la question parce que
là tu triches, c'est pas bien de faire
ça. Trois livres qui ont été importants
pour toi
dans ta construction intellectuelle, ta
façon de raisonner, ta façon de
percevoir la vie. Narcis et Goldmoon de
Herman Hess
qui est vraiment
euh l'un des bouquins, l'un des roman
que j'ai le plus adoré parce que c'est
un véritable enseignement de la vie, du
choix qui dans le livre est binaire mais
qui en réalité
recouvre
euh voilà
des réalités extrêmement différentes
dans les deux choix principaux.
Euh confession d'un enfant du siècle
d'Alfred de Musé.
C'est drôle parce que des enfants du
siècle, on en a quelques-uns. Peut-être
qu'on j'aurais l'occasion d'en reparler
chez toi dans
dans une autre dans une autre émission.
et euh Saint-Augustin.
Voilà, Saint-Augustin qui est
l'un des pères principaux de l'église
qui est reconnu par toutes les parce que
c'est un père fondateur de l'église.
Donc les catholiques, les orthodoxes et
cetera le reconnaissent. Et euh j'aime
beaucoup le les réflexions de
Saint-Augustin parce que Saint-Augustin
était quelqu'un qui avait eu une vie
dans un premier temps, une vie très
dissolue, très mondaine.
Euh et d'ailleurs
sa mère n'a cessé de prier euh pour
qu'un jour il voit il rencontre le
Christ et qu'il se convertisse. Et en
fait sa mère a été exaucée. Donc je
dirais Saint-Augustin fait partie de ces
saints qui en ayant eu une vie dans le
monde et qui ensuite a eu une vie proche
de Dieu a une pensée extrêmement
fertile, extrêmement féconde et riche
d'enseignement
pour un profane ou même pour un croyant.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable. Une
bouteille à la mer. Oui, un slogan c'est
fait "Faites le pari de votre pays.
Soyez fier de votre pays. Soyez fier de
ce que vous êtes. Arrêtez d'être
négatif. Arrêtez de considérer que la
France est un pays horrible. Aimez la
France et la France vous aimera. Je vous
le garantis.
Jean Bia, merci.
Je vous en prie et merci pour votre
invitation et merci à tous ceux qui nous
ont regardé.
[Musique]